travis what is your ideal screenwriting
life uh well you know i moved to los
angeles
to try and get into tv writing so i i've
been writing features much longer so i
i have more experience with that but tv
writing is where i want to be at you
know get the uh
stories of working with other people's
characters is is a fun challenge
uh rather than you know just being
god all the time with your own stuff so
i
thought that would be that's probably my
best place to be would be tv writing
plus
i write so fast you know pumping out
what like
six seven scripts a year so tv writing
you know they need to have that
speed to get material out you know in
time for production
so that would be appealing to you to be
in a writer's world absolutely for like
what is it 15 hours a day sometimes oh
yeah
um you know getting to especially
bouncing ideas off of other people too
you know when you're writing features
you're just kind of by yourself at your
computer and
in a writer's room you've got you know
between like four and ten other people
that we're all bouncing ideas off each
other to figure out the best possible
story for the show
so have you envisioned that do you have
like this dream board or is there
something where you're like you know
what
this is this is what my ideal life looks
like and i need to create that you know
i have never done a dream board i've
seen it i've seen it in
shows and movies where characters have
that sort of thing but i've never done
it for myself i just kind of
uh keep you know my board of what what
stuff i'm writing right now you know
keeping track of where i need to be and
deadlines and all that stuff but i've
never really
made an official visual element of of
where i want to be you know
maybe i should that would be there you
go yeah something to look at you know
so have you submitted uh spec scripts to
tv shows
um yeah uh you know i got a manager
starting last year and so it was at the
very end of staffing season though so
she'll just only get me able you know a
couple of read uh
piles um this year staffing season's
not started quite yet they're doing you
know filming the pilots right now as we
speak so
i'm already got on a couple of people's
read lists uh to consider me for
staffing so fingers crossed so that
works out well
um and then you know obviously if
i see any assignments you know on any of
like the the different
screenwriting boards you know where
producers are looking for something
specific you know you send them a spec
so they can
see if if your style works with what
they need to hire for so
an ideal show to write for or shows i'm
a big
fan of anything superhero related so
like the flash
supergirl uh superman and lois that's
gonna be coming out
this fall uh arrow unfortunately is
leaving however they're going to be
doing the spin-off of arrow and the
canaries
and i'm all on board with that um the dc
network where they've got you know the
titans and uh doom patrol and so like
anything with superheroes i'm on board
with
um any kind of like cool sci-fi stuff um
you know like a manifest that's on is is
is fun um i like a lot of
anything with superheroes or sci-fi i'm
on board with uh
i know a lot of people watch the hbo
stuff i feel like i'm the only person in
hollywood who doesn't have hbo so
i haven't seen game of thrones or
succession or any of these big things i
definitely need to be seeing put that on
the dream board
yeah exactly you know for 14 was it 14
bucks a month or something like that
right right yeah
there you go manifested what is about
the superhero genre that you're
attracted to
um i feel okay so i've never been a fan
of like
the super serious um
stories where it's like the slice of
life type stuff because i'm already
living life
i don't have superpowers i'm a superman
fanatic because
he gets to do so much cool stuff and at
the end of the day still
is a person with his wife and has a job
and all this stuff you know so
um i think it's a big thing of living
the fantasy and and being able to
live within the fantasy while you're
writing those types of characters and
situations
um and even watching it you know you're
only watching for
45 minutes plus commercials that you're
taking away to some other place you have
to think about your life while you're
watching the flash you know rescue iris
from girlagrad or something you know
telepathic gorillas people flying and
running around super speed like
we don't have that in our life so uh i
feel like that appeals to me because i
like nobody wants to live in their life
24 7. you know that's
why halloween is a big thing you know
you get to be someone else for a night
well you get to
be somebody else while you're watching
the show living vicariously through them
or writing those type of characters
uh you know imagining because i feel i
feel like most writers probably imagine
themselves in the characters that
they're writing and then
kind of living vicariously for that
amount of time you know
because like you gotta figure out okay
what would they do what would i do how
is that different um
so yeah i i've always wanted to have
super powers so i feel like that's my
my in there uh big comic book fan i have
a huge superman collection um i ever
since i was like six years old i got my
first
superman comic book and i've been
obsessed ever since then i have like
over 3000
pieces of superman memorabilia so yeah
i'm i'm obsessed with
it oh my goodness uh so yeah that's
a long answer for why i like superhero
stuff but
now that's interesting because while we
were setting up we were just talking
about sort of the
24-hour news cycle and it seems like
we're just fed so much bad news all the
time
all the time that it must be nice to to
have that difference
right so you know why why do i want to
hear about all the terrible things going
on in the world
when i can watch okay terrible thing
wearing in the city that this guy in
tights is going to fix
you know yeah exactly right and not
spandex
yeah i don't change the costume so much
now you know it used to be
like it used to be spandex though you
know you watched like uh
superman you know from back in george
reeves days you know in the 30s and 40s
like
or the 40s and and he was obviously
wearing spandex and now it's like this
weird
like under armour stuff where you can
see like all the designs throughout the
whole costume and stuff
so maybe it's more aerodynamic i don't
know
right it's breathable yeah yeah
you grew up in michigan yeah uh monroe
it's a small town
it's here okay uh little
general motors yeah well so detroit is
like up here and then i'm
down here so you know you go up a little
you go out to here to the lansing you
know and
uh down here you got ohio so i'm like
right at the border
between michigan and ohio uh about 30
minutes south
because you know we don't we don't do
miles in michigan it's it's how long
the distance is to drive there is in
minutes or hours that's true yeah so we
drive about 30 minutes north to get to
detroit
or 30 minutes south to get to delete
ohio so interesting okay
uh small towns maybe population like 350
000 so it's not like a tiny tiny town
but it's definitely much not a city size
and were there
writers people that you could emulate or
was this more
based on general motors and sort of lee
iacocca yes considered
yeah most of the stuff so in well
because we're not even far nor
far enough to detroit to have a lot of
general motors workers
so in monroe we have the edison power
plant
and they're them and then um what's it
called
i don't remember the name of it there's
a glass factory that also was like the
two of them were like the two main
employers in my town uh
power plant the glass place we also are
the home of uh lazy boy
chairs they have nice their world
corporate office is there in monroe as
well
um so they have like you know plenty of
people working there
um that's yeah those are pretty much the
main
employers in in that town so uh but i
grew up with with parents who are
teachers so they were you know working
in the school districts and stuff
oh so they fostered a love of books oh
yeah um
and writing even like my mom's biggest
punishment for us as kids
uh was writing by hand like so let's say
we said a swear word
she would make us look up the definition
of the swear word in the in the
dictionary
and then write the definition by hand
like between 50 to 100 times depending
on the severity of the curse word
and that was her primary form of
punishment for us was having to
hand write things or like if we did
something wrong with dude like the
you know you see on the simpsons when
he's writing on the chalkboard like i
will not blah blah blah
you have to do that sort of thing so i
still have terrible handwriting though
so
she couldn't read what i was writing but
you know uh you would think that my
handwriting would improve after writing
the same
thing four thousand times in an hour but
yeah not so much so then you never
viewed it as punishment it sounds like
you well there was something you found
you know it kind of started you know so
i'm already writing stuff i'm like well
as long as i'm having to write i'm also
writing my own stuff too and i you know
i won my first uh
short story contest when kindergarten uh
wrote like a is
the story was uh how daddy tried to
catch the bat
uh we seemed to get a bat would get into
the house every winter
and me and my dad would have to be the
ones to take because my
sister and my mom were terrified of bats
you know so we would
go down there with like uh tennis racket
and a fishing net you know and like
trap it between it take it outside and
stuff like that oh nice catch and
release yeah
um so we did that uh you know i i
wrote that like i said i was like
kindergarten's like five six years old
and stuff wrote that
um won a contest in that same contest it
was called the young authors
competition and it was in all all
elementary schools and junior high in
high schools and in the area basically
had
you know one person per grade got sent
there and i got sent there like six
times i
did like kindergarten like third grade
fifth grade a couple times in high
school you know so
always been writing since forever
basically
when you told them that you wanted to
come to los angeles to
be a tv writer what was their impression
uh
it kind of mixed um you know because
there's obviously
no guarantee writing is like the hardest
thing to make money at you know so
um growing up even like when i you know
wanted to
do something in the arts you know
because i used to sing choirs and stuff
too when i was growing up so like i want
to be a singer for a while i want to be
a writer
be a poet you know um all this other
stuff so they're like well you know
though that's great
but you need to wait find a way to make
money too you know so
um because like i i've even mentioned in
my book
how hard it is to be like there's a
statistic in the book that
it's actually there are more working
football players in the nfl than there
are working writers in the wga
so it's hugely you know hard to get into
because there's so many people doing it
and so many talented people doing it too
you know so
you could be an amazing writer in your
hometown and you're just
one of a number out here in l.a i think
you've said that it happened one night
is one of your favorite films yeah
that's my favorite
oh it is yeah um i love that movie and i
feel like
even though it was you know came out in
the 30s i feel like
the the dialogue on it like there's a
few quirky things you know that no one
would ever say nowadays that was like
slang for for that time
but for the most part the story and a
lot of the dialogue could even still
come out today i feel like and still be
a viable thing you'd have to change
you know some of the what they consider
risque
things you know and update it and stuff
but i i think it's fantastic and
you know the acting in it is great and
yeah i love i think it's like the one
flawless and a lot of people think
uh we'll say casablanca as like their
flawless movie
casalong is great but i i'm a big big
fan of it happened one night
so it's claudette colbert and um
not uh clark gabriel park park okay and
so he's this journalist and she's like
this wealthy
yeah she's like an heiress like a paris
hilton type of person back then you know
and her dad wants her to marry you know
it's her person the person she wants to
marry he doesn't like and so she he's
like willing to
they want to like disown her and stuff
so she runs away to go and
marry the guy she wants to marry and so
the dad puts out basically like a bounty
on his own daughter to
find you know if you can bring her back
to me like you'll get so much money
and uh this reporter who's an
out-of-work reporter
who's not on good terms with his boss
accidentally sees her like on a bus they
end up riding the bus together and
he kind of like ends up trailing her and
makes the deal with her that he won't
turn her in for the money
if she gives him the exclusive on
everything that's happening so they end
up
going cross-country together with him
taking notes and of course they slowly
fall in love along the way even though
they start off you know despising each
other like most romances seem to do in
movies
don't like each other when you meet but
by the end you're in love so uh
yeah yeah i think it's a fantastic film
travis when did you move to los angeles
and why
2016 uh august 26th yeah i've only been
out here a couple years
wow okay um and again because i wanted
to get into television writing like you
can write features anywhere but if you
want to do tv you got to be out here
where the rooms are
um you know they might film in other
places you know like vancouver is a big
place to film because of all the film
incentives that they have you know like
tax budget
tax breaks and stuff like that uh but
the rooms are all still out here in los
angeles there's a couple in new york but
mostly out here
um so since i wanted to do tv writing i
kind of had to be where the rooms are
and moved out here
uh to do that and what were you doing
prior to 2016 what was life like
uh for travis so i moved here from
virginia beach
um so i like i'm originally from
michigan i moved from michigan
to virginia in 2011. uh to be a massage
therapist
yeah i've done a lot of jobs in my life
so i moved there to be a massage
therapist did that for a few years kind
of got burned out on it
um and then was working as a
dispatcher for an alarm security company
oh but also
yeah and but still writing on on the
side you know for
for writing so like i got hired when i
was working there
got hired to write eight episodes of a
sci-fi series in the uk
that to the best of my knowledge still
has not come out and that was
you know years ago now um and
wrote like a bunch of different features
for like independent producers
all around the country like a lot of
people when i tell them out here that oh
yeah i was getting
jobs in virginia and they're like oh
well that's different out here no i was
writing for hollywood
producers like low budget hollywood
producers from virginia
uh you know so i was still doing the
writing but
doing all these other odd jobs on the
side as well
and did you fly out or drive i drove uh
yeah so i actually
took me a couple days to get out here
because i drove from virginia beach i
drove up to michigan so i could see my
parents because i hadn't seen them in a
couple years since i had moved
um i still haven't seen my sister even
since when was the last time i saw naoka
uh like 2011 i think like i think it was
like the first year i had moved away and
i came back for christmas that's the
last time i even see my sister
so hopefully she comes up to my wedding
later this year
do you want to give her an invitation
right now or well she she's okay
she's she's one of my best men basically
she's
nice i have grooms people you know there
we go yeah so
i had to have my sister in there but
yeah so i moved
so when i was moving i drove up to
michigan spent like a day or so with my
parents
uh and then drove the rest of the way
out here like i made a couple stops
like overnight because it's too far to
drive in one thing so i think i stopped
in
kansas city and then a second stop in
phoenix where my cousin lives and
hung out with him for a day and then got
out here and then had my first
hollywood meeting like two days after i
arrived so
with a manager it didn't go so well uh
unfortunately um
but you know his first meeting can't
really expect because i didn't know what
to do at my first meeting all my
experience before then was either
meetings on the phone or via email you
know so
i feel like i babbled like i did like
i'm doing now well
i'm actually maybe just leaving out
names to protect the
innocent or not so innocent what what
was what do you think
went poorly about it um
the fact that i didn't really know how
to conduct a meeting
uh first off so i was kind of going off
on
various tangents on all my various
projects uh
it was the manager so they want to know
like your best thing and what you do
um not everything you've ever written
kind of thing you know and so i was
sitting there going
oh i've written this horror and i've
written this sci-fi and i've written
this thing for tv and movies and blah
blah
and it's like when you get done so many
things you don't want to mention all
those things because nobody cares at a
certain point you know like
um especially when things aren't being
produced so
uh that's my the one advice i probably
break my own advice
often enough and stuff is don't tell
everyone when you're when you're having
a meeting with the manager don't tell
them every single thing up front
you know it's only like in dates yeah oh
i've had some bad days where i've done
that for sure
um yeah okay so like you're going on so
like
going off way too f onto way too many
tangents telling wait like over
sharing like crazy um did not go well
and then not really knowing i guess like
where you fit in the industry um
is kind of hurtful uh because you want
like there's so many people out there
who want to do
all these other things you go to like a
networking thing and you're people who
are like
8 000 hyphenates oh i'm a writer
director producer
art director blah blah you know or
people who are like oh yeah i can write
everything
i write drama and horror and comedy no
you don't
you write like one thing really well you
might be interested in writing those
things you might even have scripts and
other things but
there's no way you write equally well
across the board in every genre it's
just not happening
do you think it was just being eager and
maybe
you know the industry hadn't beaten you
down and so you didn't know
and you were just being innocently eager
um possibly
um but i feel like again that kind of
goes with like a naivete about how the
industry really works
um you know having again not having had
any in-person time like face-to-face
with with hollywood industry
folks it was just you know sending out
an email or being on the phone with
somebody
um reading screenwriting books and stuff
you know
they usually tell you like how to write
the scripts there's not really a lot of
business oriented books out there so
um you don't really learn how to conduct
a meeting very well unless you're
actually doing it because
you can have all the theory on it you
want but until you're face to face with
somebody
uh knowing how you're gonna behave with
them totally different
when you finished that meeting did you
already have an intuition about this
didn't go well yeah
kind of um kind of like when you go for
an interview for a job you kind of
have an idea if it went well or not
right
but you know i've had meetings with
producers too where i have
no clue how it went when i walked out
because they're so straight faced
they're not giving anything away and
then like so you could think you did
terribly and then they call you the next
day
want you to come and write their thing
you know so it's hard to gauge usually
but i feel like in that particular case
i kind of
knew that it wasn't going to go the way
i wanted it to go when i walked out so
when they start when they start checking
their
watch or their phone and stuff part way
through the
meeting you know that's not a good thing
with the phone thing it might just be
typical etiquette
these days with with people you know
being glued to
their communication but when you left
that meeting
what was your feeling about being in l.a
you'd been here what two days
yeah i had gotten here sunday night
of that week and the interview the
meeting with her was tuesday morning so
yeah
like a day and a half maybe um
i know when i was moving i hear people
were telling me about like
all the traffic and i'm going to be
sitting on the freeway forever but i'm
so against i'm originally from detroit
area like nobody lives in detroit but
people work there you know so it's like
the commute that way so the only
difference is here it's much shorter
distances
in the traffic so um but the weather is
fantastic i hate snow which is why i
wanted to get out of michigan to begin
with and the snow followed me to
virginia
because a friend of mine who lives in in
virginia where i moved to told me oh
there's no snow here ever
like first year i moved there blizzard
of like 13 inches
every year i lived there it was at least
eight inches
out here i have not a single day of snow
it's fantastic i love it
so then you you still had your hopes up
or did you oh absolutely
i you i'm not one to easily get down
especially knowing
like i said how hard it is anyway so um
it's just
sticking notch on the belt kind of thing
oh here's another no okay
moving on let's you can't just let the
nose get to you otherwise like
you will drop out of this business like
immediately like even
like spielberg is even getting no's and
he's steven spielberg you know
you're always going to get the nose and
because you can't uh you can't appease
everybody's tastes and everything you
know so like i've had
i've had scripts that in one contest
doesn't even get the quarterfinals
another one will be a semi-finalist
give my top two or something like that
you have people when
having getting notes on scripts where
one person will love this scene and talk
about how amazing the scene is the next
person's like oh this is a terrible
scene it needs to change
it's like they're talking about the
exact same thing and one person loves it
one person hates it so
you know you can't really base
your feelings on the industry and one
person's opinion is
you know you kind of got to keep keep
going and keep trying and
getting your stuff out there
when did you start calling yourself a
screenwriter probably
my second or third script like my first
script it was kind of
you know i was writing about like a
personal experience and i was just kind
of it was almost like therapy for me at
the time
and so then probably my second script
i was an aspiring screenwriter like i
was like oh this is fun i want to do
this
and i probably got my third maybe fourth
script is when i was like oh yeah i'm a
screenwriter i'm not getting paid yet
but i'm a screenwriter like this is
where i'm going
uh and then my fifth script was a paid
script so i was like i
already made it come true awesome it
wasn't very big paid because it was a
small like local person i think it got
paid like 500 bucks or something like
that
um to write a feature uh that never got
made
so but yeah i probably by third or
fourth script is when i went from being
an aspiring experiencer like yes this is
what i'm
doing with my life did someone say
to you don't call yourself an aspiring
writer oh you will always get haters who
say like if you're not making money at
it you shouldn't call yourself a
screenwriter like
uh you know they're like oh you wouldn't
call yourself a plumber because you
fixed your own toilet well
i'm still writing screenplays and you
know i'm not doing it just for myself
i'm
still trying to get my stuff out into
the world whether it's being paid or not
because you know when writing a spec
script
you're not paid for writing that spec so
are you not a screenwriter because it
hasn't sold yet like you still wrote the
thing
it takes time effort energy heart blood
soul everything goes into these scripts
you know so you're
absolutely if you're if you're actually
doing the work you're absolutely a
screenwriter
um i feel like the only way that you're
not is if you're someone who
says you're a screenwriter and aren't
doing any work towards it i've
met people who are like i'm a
screenwriter okay great what have you
worked on oh well i haven't read
anything yet
but i want to be welcome to los angeles
exactly
right yeah uh i i heard um
you know on twitter i follow a lot of
show runners and and stuff like that and
there was a show runner i'm trying to
remember who it was now that it was like
a couple weeks ago
that they met someone at a party um they
knew who she was
and what what show she was on and
they're like oh well
you know i would love to write on your
show that it's fantastic and they had
built a rapport before we brought it up
which is good
um and then she said okay well sure send
me over a sample he didn't have any
samples
he had not written a single thing but
he's telling her how much he wants to
write for her show
wow and yeah it's like why why are you
bringing that up if you don't have
anything to
to show and prove yourself you know to
them um
because like oh well in that case i want
to go and play you know
baseball but i don't have the experience
on it i want to so
as soon as you're doing the work you're
a screenwriter
okay that makes sense and so what i was
also wondering is did did you feel like
you held yourself back because you were
calling yourself
for i think after your second script and
aspiring right i don't think i was
holding myself back i think it was uh
i think it was more of like i didn't
have the nerve to call myself that yet
because i was so inexperienced
um and i wasn't sure if that's what i
wanted to do and be with
you know have as my career it was just
something at the time was
for fun because like like i said the
first script i wrote is like a therapy
for a situation i was in at the time
my second script i wrote a superman
script not knowing that you can't write
you know material because of like
copyright infringements and stuff like
that i didn't know that it was a thing
yet at that time
i was in my like early 20s so didn't
really
know that you couldn't write a superman
script and send it out there but it was
fun and figured out what doesn't doesn't
work in the writing especially for
action sequences and
um but then by my my third and fourth
thing like i said i was
starting to write my own original
material at that point then and
that's when i became a screenwriter as
opposed to just somebody who has fun
doing it
how do you motivate yourself to write
every day
so this is a discussion i've had with
other writers because i'm very prolific
and that i write like i said lots of
material a year and i write every day if
i can help it um
occasionally i can't because i've got
like too many chores and
errands to have to run where i can't
find time to sit there
um but i'm of the belief that if you
if you want to be a writer you need to
actually be writing
um so i don't need motivation i just
need to get my butt in the seat and do
the work
um might not always be fantastic stuff
than pumping out if
you know if i'm sitting there just to
write just to get
the pages out but um the act of writing
is something that you need to do every
single day or as frequently as you can
in order to keep doing it because if you
write just when
you're motivated to write like if you're
not motivated to write for like months
at a time you're not going to get any
material written
and if you especially since i want to do
tv writing like you can't just be like
oh sorry boss i don't i don't feel like
writing my episode today
i'll give it to you next week if i feel
like it doesn't fly
so you kind of have to motivate it or
not you can't just wait for the muse to
hit you have to
you know force the muse sometimes and
and
tell her okay get your wings in here
because i'm writing now it's time
you know so uh yeah i don't really go
with
needing to motivate it's just i'm i have
to write i'm
writing it's something i have to do it's
not something i
always want to do because sometimes
you're like oh i would much rather go to
the beach today and then be sitting at
my computer screen but
you're not going to get stuff done that
way so i i don't need the motivation to
write i just
i am the motivation i write i'm a little
writing machine basically so
stick me up for my computer pages are
going to get pumped out
one interesting thing about like having
a day job is
i found that that i always want to be
doing something else but then once you
have that free time
i don't know if it's fear or what it is
then all of a sudden it's like ah and
then you find all these excuses
do you ever fall prey to that oh
absolutely um because i do have a day
job unfortunately
um so uh luckily my day job i have
plenty of down time at the day job where
i can do some writing you know
there i can't be in final draft at the
work computer
but i can be you know like outlining in
a notebook or something like that you
know to at least get some ideas
down to to fix issues i may have in the
script at home
um but then yeah like i i am not good at
staying awake late
like at all like midnight i'm i'm out um
so i get home from my day job at like 10
30 at night
i have enough time to to walk the dog
with my fiance and then watch
maybe an episode of tv and then i'm gone
so i do all my writing in the morning
when i wake up
i'm up you know between eight and eight
thirty every morning
uh pump out between two to four hours
worth of writing before i go to work
every day so and then on my days off i
used to write a ton
uh but i was getting super stressed
apparently and so my fiance would have
stopped that
she's like nope on your day's off you're
not writing sorry uh if you need to for
a uh
like a deadline or something like that
you know i just had to do a rewrite
um on a script feature of mine that's
going to be getting filmed in a couple
months and and
so they had their their notes for the
final rewrite and they're like okay we
need to have this by this day so we can
get it to our actors and stuff so
um i got to write on on those days uh
it's more of like one of those i get to
kind of scenarios i feel very
bad if i went a whole day and didn't
write anything so
um because i just feel like i should be
writing
you know it's to the point now where
once you do something it becomes habit
you know what is it like you do
something for 30 days it becomes a habit
for you and you'll keep doing it so
writing every day i at this point it's
it's not a oh i feel like writing today
it's i have to write i can't do anything
else until i get my pages done
so do you have this ritual in the
morning where you like get your coffee
ready oh i don't drink coffee well
you're not oh you know
i was force-fed coffee as a child
because it does the same thing that
as ritalin in young children because of
the difference in metabolism versus
adults
so you know the in children they burn
through the caffeine much faster it
has like a ritalin type effect where it
kind of calms them down and ritalin when
i was a kid
like gave me really bad stomach cramps
and so the doctor was like oh give him a
cup of coffee every morning and do the
same thing
so yeah so i had to drink coffee every
morning before school from the age of
six to the age of 16
and i so i won't drink it now my fiance
loves coffee
and i think it's gross okay i won't put
it in my mouth
it's an expensive habit if you get the
right especially if you're going with
starbucks you know where you're dropping
like four or five bucks on a cup
like you know um but yeah so i
i don't really do that but uh i
definitely i wake up
um if sometimes i'll go work out like
i'm trying to do like the new year's
resolution thing of
hitting the treadmill a couple times a
week sometimes i do it as many times as
i need to but not usually
um so you know hit the treadmill if i'm
able if i have the energy to do it um
otherwise hit the computer i have a
really bad habit checking my email first
so i know i've heard many people say
don't do that like you know once
like stephen king says don't check your
email until you've already done your
morning writing and then check your
email later on in the day i can't do
that i have to
i've got too many things coming in from
producers
newsletters of where like i want to read
these articles and stuff you know
so i'll i'll set aside the articles but
at least got to go through i'm also very
organized in my email um most people
you know they'll have like their junk
mail just sitting there forever and have
like 10
you look on their phone they've got 10
000 emails that are unread yeah i
go through meticulously and i even have
folders for every
topic so i will like move to so if it's
a you know if it's a
on a certain movie that like i'm talking
back like right now i'm working on a web
series and so if i get an email from
the producer for the web series it goes
to his folder and if i get something
that is from my fiance about our wedding
plans i'll move that to our wedding
folder and i'll you know so
i only ever have in my inbox like
at most like 10 or 12 emails because i
read things and then file it away to
where it goes and and
delete all my junk mail before i read
anything i need to read so
that takes probably way too much time to
do all that and then i start writing
once i've done all my email and my and
checking like the social media
briefly and um writing
probably start so i wake up at eight uh
probably start writing
nine nine thirty depending on how much
junk mail there's a sift through
uh and then i'll write until about like
10 30 or 11 when we gotta walk the dog
then i'll make breakfast for my
me and my fiance and then usually have a
working breakfast eating there while i'm
still typing away pages till about like
maybe 12 and then take a shower start
getting ready for my day job and then
out the door by one so
uh yeah so writing for like i said
between
two to four hours a day every day before
going to work what's stephen king's
logic
uh for not checking emails before
writing that it's just a time waste
um and and it's something that you can
get carried away with as i just proved
i'm sitting there
moving everything around and checking
everything and filing things away
it can get to the point where you know i
all of a sudden i've waited i've been
sitting there for an hour and a half and
i haven't done anything that's not email
yet you know and
um you know the the writing needs to
come first
so i know that that's what i should be
doing i just can't seem to
peel myself away from my email and to
save it for later
um i feel like i have to know all the
things that are going on especially with
like i said the the web series i'm
working on like the producers in
in barcelona yeah so the time difference
i have
like he sends me stuff i'm already
asleep when he sends me stuff so now i'm
getting it and have to respond and
stuff like that so um yeah i think i
think that's the logic of don't check
your email to later like get your pages
done
first at least someone even if you're
gonna like let's say you have the goal
of writing okay i'm gonna write 10 pages
today okay write your first five pages
then when you need a break
you check your email and stuff then make
sure you come back to it you know so
um or save it towards later of the day
because i could potentially just you
know check all my email at work
at my day job you know but i'm just
obsessed i don't know
what it is well i think certain people
have things about like they need the
house
in somewhat of yeah or there's like
different things oh everyone has some
kind of procrastination
tool for sure you know like or need for
order though i think people need
order sometimes don't you think
maybe i don't know i i know writers who
you know they they won't start writing
until their desk is exactly the way it
needs to be for the day
and that could take them a while
cleaning stuff off putting their coffee
just so you know making sure the light's
coming through a certain angle and stuff
like no just write if you're gonna write
start writing so
i don't know because i know i need i
should change my email to later on
but uh as of right now it's my
procrastination tool i wake up i check
my email
right so
what's the formula for a bad story i
feel like there's many ways that a
story could go bad um not picking the
right character
to be the lead i've definitely have read
scripts
where the lead character is much
less interesting than like a secondary
character in the script it's like why
are you putting the focus here um being
completely plot driven to the point
where we don't really have characters
what if the whole story is just set
piece after set piece and we don't care
about what's going on or who the people
are
in the cool set pieces it can be as cool
as you want and still kind of
fail because there's not enough of a
story there
you know um
not uh not having any kind of
connection i think is probably the
biggest the biggest bad
thing that you'll see in a script is you
know having the wrong character or not
caring about the character
um i know that uh
anti-heroes are like a big thing
nowadays you know like the joker movie
and and breaking bad the series let me
know and so a lot of people think
you know because it used to be that oh
you have to like the character well you
don't necessarily have to like the
character
no if anybody liked the character and
joker there's something wrong with them
um you know it's a great it's a good
movie but
it's like if you can get on board with
that character doing those awful things
there's nothing wrong with you but the
thing is you care about the character
right because you know they're they're
doing the bad things but like you're
seeing
in addition to the bad stuff you're
seeing like the human side of the
character
there's something that you can connect
to you know like taxi driver even which
again is a similar story to joker and
stuff they're doing the bad stuff but
like
they've got humanistic things about them
you know that that connects you um where
and like even superhero movies you know
like
those quotes from some famous directors
that we won't throw under the bus
you know you know oh super hero movies
you know they're just like a
roller coaster ride or whatever he said
it was it's like but
you know if like superhero movies done
well you care about the character like
that's the thing that
like marvel does really well you know in
in their movies is
that you care about the superheroes it's
not just this
guy in an iron suit who can blow stuff
up with you know repulsor cannons or
whatever it's called
like you care about him and his
interactions with other people around
him
and his you know how he wants to solve
the problem
um if it was just a faceless person
in a thing blowing stuff up there's no
nothing there to care about
you know so that's probably the biggest
bad thing people do is not giving us
something to hold on to for the
character
do you think that the level of empathy
has improved like i'm
forgive me i i don't know much about the
superheroes so i'm hoping you can
educate me on
sure so let's take christopher reeves as
supe superman
uh in the end as you should okay all
right so um
do you think that version of superman
has
evolved in terms of some of the
humanistic qualities they give to him um
so like our if we like we're to compare
that one with like some of the more
recent
supermen um i feel
i love okay i love christopher superman
i love henry cavill at superman they're
fantastic but they're
very different superman um the movies
obviously the tone is much darker
in the new one than than the one in the
80s
different time yeah different things in
the world but
there's still in each of them they still
have
human traits like they're this alien
from outer space who has god-like powers
but they were raised as a person you
know so they're not
um superman
is his secret identity he's clark kent
if you think of the stuff because he was
raised by mom paul kent to be a good
person long before he even had the
ability to knock over buildings and
you know carry kryptonite planet their
rocks
mountains into the space you know like
like happened because in uh superman
returns you know brandon ralph's
superman
which is a continuation but okay um
i can go into too much superman stuff
but the point is
they were people they were humans and
they were brought up as
good people from their parents before
they had the ability to do god-like
things
you know so if they were just if it was
just somebody who
was automatically born already had the
superpowers and
because there are so in comic books um
one thing that dc used to do
was the uh the elseworlds stories
and there's my favorite one is uh
superman red sun they're gonna have an
animated version of come out later this
year i'm psyched for
um where he you know crash landed in
um soviet russia and he was basically
raised as the superman the ubermensch
uh you know so he basically became their
weapon you know
during like the the wars and stuff and
so
uh it's it's a whole nurture versus
nature thing
you know of of how he was raised because
his his humanity is much
lower in red sun than it ever was in the
main continuity because he was raised by
mom paul kent
over here whereas over here he was you
know raised by
you know soldiers and and the government
and stuff like that to be a weapon
um i don't know where i'm going with
that but i don't know i think
i think you you've you've touched on it
so we're trying to
it sounds like because of the timing
of so the 80s that the world was
definitely a different place
you had fears and there were things
looming but it seems like today
uh the intensity and then hence the
story is darker
yeah so the tone is darker but but he's
even if you look at him as a character
though he still got raised by mom paul
kent so he still makes
you know humanistic choices even when
he's fighting against
zod you know one thing that everybody in
for the new
superman movie with henry cavill the
people didn't like him in man of steel
was that he end up killing zod at the
end
spoiler alert if you didn't see it yet
um
they're like oh no superman would never
kill but the so it's a much darker
thing but it's he still made the choice
to save human life
you know because that's the way he was
raised you know like his
his own dad you know made him
not be superman basically to save
other people and stuff because it would
oust him well in this case he's
doing whatever it takes to save those
people because he couldn't save people
before
so and then going back to the
christopher e version
he's you know doing whatever it takes to
save the people like putting himself in
harm's way with like the kryptonite and
then
having to go along the missiles granted
in the old one he got to fly around the
earth to save lois and reverse time
which our guy didn't get to do but uh
he's still making all of his choices
based on
a human quality as opposed to a superman
quality he's just
a human who gets to do the superman
quality which is why i say that superman
it's not that clark kent is not his
superman here at any superman is clark
kent's secret identity
do writers want to control their story
world
and if so what should they accept as out
of their control
so there's a couple different schools of
thought i guess that writers seem to
have
um you've got writers who think that
they are god
and all these characters must bow to
their whim because they're the ones
telling the story i'm kind of one of
those writers
there are other writers who let the
story tell itself where they
they you know basically sit back and
they're just like unraveling
as the characters are coming up with the
ideas i find that the people in the
second group
who are just letting the story tell
itself are also the ones who don't
outline and may get lost in the trenches
along the way
i'm a serial outliner i will not start
page one until
i have a bulletproof story i will do my
outline
and then do a rewrite on the outline and
do a rewrite on the outline and until
like the story as as flawless as i can
personally make it before i even start
writing the script and then i'm just
adding dialogue basically at that point
um so i have complete control over
everything
uh things might change a little bit in
the drafting like if something doesn't
work
once i'm actually writing out the longer
version of it then i might make some
tweaks but for the most part it sticks
almost identical to my outline or the
point where i'm literally crossing off
scenes on my outline as soon as i finish
typing it move on to the next one
whereas the people who don't outline and
or let the characters
live their own lives they seem to
meander more in the story
and as they're letting it go wherever it
wants to go well that's a very good way
to suddenly have like a 400 page script
in front of you
and you know uh in that case i feel like
those people should are more geared
better towards novels
you know where they can go off and on
these long
tangents that don't really connect to
the story other than they're still using
the characters
um so i think that's
so yeah the two different types of
writers and i find that for the most
part those who want to play god
are the outliners and those who you know
let the story live itself
don't outline as much and have a
tendency of either going off on tangents
or just getting lost and not knowing
what's coming next
when you talked about how you almost
thought it was a detriment to
organize your email i'm wondering if
that's actually a strength because
you like that organization and so that
that sort of lends itself to this
outline
it's possible um you know because i do i
don't do like the
like the the blake schneider like beat
outline like i
do full scenes like i i basically write
out full paragraphs of everything
um everything except dialogue i almost
have like a really cool dialogue that
possibly then already down for the most
part i
my outlines are you know they're not
super long uh i'd say maybe
between 10 and 20 pages do you number
sorry i don't but i do like i
do a scene heading like i know like the
locations i want these things i still
have slugs
uh for each of my things even in my
outline um
so like you know like this scene takes
place internal office and an
external house blah blah but i don't sit
there and number
the scenes um i don't really find that
super important
um because one scene
could be multiple scenes once you're in
script form you know like if something's
in
inside a house you could have a scene in
the living room and in the kitchen and
the dining room and it's one big one
sequence but then it's like broken down
into like three or four scenes you know
so i feel like
numbering it isn't really going to help
me much i'm still just going scene by
scene
or sequence by sequence as it may be
anyway
um so yeah i don't number i don't want
to see a point
what's the most you've ever rewritten
and outline
revised it i have a script james hook
it's an origin story of captain hook
from peter pan
um the outline went through about
four rewrites um
then the script itself went through a
ton of rewrites too because
even when i finished it when i had the
outline as solid as i thought i could
get it
it was like an 18-page outline the first
draft of the script was 176 pages
way too long so a lot of stuff like
got changed you know because it was way
too long and
while trying to fix how to get rid of
things
i started seeing like oh well these two
scenes
could be combined they weren't over here
because it seemed important they were
individual
scenes but now i need it shorter and so
it's easier to just combine these
a few story elements even you know
changed along the way
based on reader notes whereas like in my
head it was like oh this is fabulous
because you're spending so much time
with the story you might not always see
everything that
that is wrong with it so once i send
stuff out certain readers are like oh
this comes across as kind of racist or
this comes as sexist or this doesn't
work at all because of this thing that
happened back here
that like you might not see it as as
clearly so that's why i always get notes
i always do
like i do all the outlining myself i
don't really show my outlines anybody
um and then i do my first draft
and then i do my own rewrite on it
before i send out anybody so
nobody sees my story until it's at least
a second draft of the script
um and then luckily i get very good
notes to find things that
didn't occur to me even while reading
and rereading my own stuff um
i feel like we have a tendency of
getting lost in our own work and falling
too much in love with things and then
not seeing that something doesn't work
because you love it it's such a cool
scene but sometimes those really cool
scenes are the things that
aren't working in any capacity other
than being cool
um and so if you can tweak things to
make them better
you should has anyone ever tried to talk
you out of doing an outline like you
know travis you're spending too much
absolutely um because again i'm a serial
outliner i have
i have outlined occur as of right now
this today i have outlines for
14 features and nine pilots
that i haven't written yet so um people
are like why am i spending a lot of time
and
i've tried writing without an outline
before i have two scripts that i
actually did write without
outlining first and it was hell to write
them because i didn't know
what was coming next and that infuriated
me so much that i'm like i don't know
how to get these characters out of this
because i'm just trying to write off the
cuff you know and
um one of those scripts hasn't like
nothing's happened with it and because
i'm like it's
it's cool and i like it but i don't
i it's it's also very short um
you know like your features should be
you know like the 90 to 120 page
in that range you know 90 to 120 and i
think this script is like 82 pages
and it's because you know i'm writing it
out and like
it nothing nothing there wasn't a lot of
material
there of like just coming up with the
full story in script form whereas if i
if i were to have like outlined it first
i would have seen ahead of time oh my
outline's kind of short
like what else is there that needs to be
beefy you know into the story so um and
then the other script that i wrote
without an outline
was a page quarterfinalist and has been
optioned by two different producers
over the years you know so um i don't
necessarily know that it's
the process not working in a script or
for the script not working but
for me writing both of those script no
matter how good one of them
may have been to to get option and place
in contest
it was hell to write because i never
knew what was happening
and had to constantly be fixing things
on the fly
where it's much harder to fix a problem
in a 90-page script than it is in like a
5-10 page outline you know
if you're outlining something it's only
10 pages and scenes need to be
rearranged you can just
move scenes around and see how it works
and re-read the whole thing again
in like what 15-20 minutes of reading to
see if it works whereas if you
move something around in a feature you
could end up leaving things behind and
of course then it's going to affect
things in the future
i would much rather rewrite you know if
i move something at near the end
like let's say it was on page eight of
my ten page outline i moved to page
seven i'd rather
rewrite three pages you know as i need
to
rather than in a script having to
rewrite 30 pages of stuff that because
it changes everything around it
interesting okay so it sounds like that
works because it seems like a lot of
people have an opposition
to the uh outline so it sounds like if
you couldn't do it
it would really hinder it it hurts like
i
i feel like i know writing is
a lot of people say writing is supposed
to be hard um
i don't necessarily believe that i don't
find that
writing is hard if as long as you find
the time to actually write i think it's
more an issue of writing well is hard
um coming up with the story that works
and
again i would much rather try to work
that story out in 10 pages
rather than trying to like fix something
that was 90 pages
you know uh i've seen i saw
on twitter a writer recently uh he's a
professional writer
works on a good tv show who
they were just trash talking the
outlining process completely and i'm
like well
that's fine for you if you don't need
outline then by all means i have another
friend who
refuses to outline and her scripts are
fantastic
but if you need to outline and i do
definitely outline and don't listen to
the people who are trash talking
outlining do the process that works for
you
i think you finished a first feature
script
was it 2005. yeah 2005. that was the one
i had mentioned earlier
that was like a personal thing that had
gone through and i was kind of writing
as a therapy
sort of thing i didn't know any of the
rules of screenwriting anything like
that
um i was just kind of working out my own
issues with it you know with what was
going on
in my life so sorry this was at the
alarm company no i don't know
2005 no 2005 um
i was still in michigan in 2005. oh okay
um
massage therapy no that was before then
even because i didn't go to massage
school to 2010.
so it doesn't i gotta think where i was
let's see i
i would have been at that time working
in a
movie theater as a concessions clerk oh
nice
um as one of my jobs i think i had four
jobs simultaneously at that time
okay so yeah i won't go into the details
of what the personal issue was
sure that's fine um although which is
weird i still have
people who have read a bunch of my
scripts who still think that's my best
script to date and i'm like that's
impossible because i've written like so
many scripts since then but
that is interesting yeah maybe it's
because it's my most personal thing you
know because i was
it was literally i was taking the stuff
that was happening to me and
made the exact same things happen to the
character and then just kind of
the things i wish i would have done
differently in the situation made the
character do to get out of it kind of
thing
um and so you were at the you had four
jobs
one of which was a concession stand at a
movie theater you're writing this script
in the morning still
um that was kind of like whenever i
could sort of thing because i i
like i said my very first script i
didn't know anything about screenwriting
i
think i wrote that in ms word uh at the
time so
yeah i didn't know anything i was just
um
it was literally just my way of venting
the stuff the stuff that was happening
you know to me so
um it wasn't until after that that i
like said my second and third script
when i started doing other things like i
wanted to do like a superman thing
whatever and when you look at that
script
where and where you were at during that
time what kind of writing misconceptions
do you think you had
versus now maybe things just feel more
clear to you
right i didn't i had never even seen a
screenplay yet by that point
um so i i think i kind of wrote like the
dialogue like i had seen in plays
because i used to do like plays musicals
in high school you know um
so i was kind of like going by that so
like i had
instead of having character dialogue
character die i had
character dialogue character you know so
and then
oh he um didn't really know what a slug
line was so everything was just written
like a
novel almost but then had like so like
yeah it was basically written like a
novel with
uh interesting stage play dialogue
character setup um i rewrote it
once i learned about screenwriting i had
read scripts because i started working
as a production assistant
in 2007 2008 somewhere on there
um then as a production assistant uh
working in the
myself was one of one of my jobs was
collating scripts you know and sending
out people so
i'm started reading so i'm like oh
that's how it's supposed to look
gotcha all right so then went back to
like that script and all the scripts i'd
written and then like
change the formatting up and stuff
how many screenplays have you sold sold
i haven't sold
any i've sold a couple shorts which is
bizarre to me that there's a market for
shorts
but apparently there there is there's
even um i've heard of some actually big
sales of shorts in fact one of the
people
who has one of my features optioned
right now they got their start
working for a producer who was making
short films for like
sony and they were giving him like 100
budgets on each of these short films
yeah i'm like
i don't i don't know what they did with
with a hundred thousand dollar short
film at that point but
um there's apparently a market for him
so i've sold two
shorts i've been hired to write a bunch
of shorts
i've optioned i currently have three
features that are out on option
but total i've optioned seven features
that i've had option but then they
didn't turn into sales
um i know one of them was because like
they couldn't get the director that they
wanted
and they basically had their mind as
that director or nobody sort of thing so
they
one had
optioned a thriller script of mine and
then when they were looking for
investments
they found an investor to to give them
like a very large sum of money
but only if it was for a slate of family
friendly features and mine did not fit
the bill
so it went it unfortunately went away um
but yeah
i've got of the three that are currently
optioned two of them are supposed to
turn into sales within the next couple
of months so i'm hoping that that works
out
um but yeah so far i don't have any like
full-on feature sales
uh as of as of today so can you explain
the optioning process
sure so an option is kind of like
a uh a rent to own sort of scenario you
see like those
you know if you go on craigslist looking
for an apartment or something they'll
have like lease to own sort of things
on like condos and stuff so it's sort of
that situation where they will pay you
an obscenely small amount of money uh
sometimes
as little as a dollar to have the rights
to the script for between six months and
a year usually
um so that way you can't be shopping
around to other people
so they know they're the only person who
has the ability to make that movie and
they're going around
uh trying to find either talent or
investments or both
um so then they can raise the money to
make the movie
if they succeed then they will buy
the script from you so then they can
make it if they don't succeed their
options are
either a renew the option for a slightly
less low amount of money um so if it was
a dollar the first time around it might
be like okay now we gotta pay you like
500 bucks you know
um in order to get like an additional
year
um or they can just be like okay we
couldn't get it done
it's yours again do it what you want
with it so
i've had scripts that after that first
year
they couldn't do anything with it so
it's mine again um
one of the three that i've optioned
right now they've renewed the option
like three times
so i don't i don't know what i know
they've had like different successes and
failures with it along the way
so i'm hoping that they get more
successes but
until then i'm getting money every year
just for them to keep being able to shop
it around
sort of thing so um yeah that's that's
what an option is they pay you a little
amount to
have the rights to shop it around and
then which is slightly different
shopping agreement
um because in a shopping agreement
unless it's
an exclusive shopping agreement like you
could still potentially
sell to other people um a shopping even
an exclusive shopping agreement
they are getting the rights to like
bring it around but they can only bring
it to like
select people they can't just like
blanket the town with it with under a
shopping agreement you know they have to
go
to specific either investors or or
networks or depending on if it's tv or
feature
um like i currently have
i have one of my scripts out on a
shopping agreement and i have a shopping
agreement that i own on a book
that i wanted to adapt all right um so
for the shopping agreement there was
like no money
and i can only shop it around to
specific people like i can't
i can't even tell people what the script
is
unless it's a producer who can get it
made
like you know so nobody everyone knows
oh i wrote an
adaption but they're like why why can't
you tell me what it is because my
shopping agreement is that i can only
shop it to
people who can buy it so nobody else can
even know it exists um other than
knowing that i wrote it you know and
they can't know what
what the script is then go find the book
or anything like that so
um and it's a similar thing on the
script that i have out
with a producer it's on a shopping
agreement is that they can only talk
about it
to investors or other producers like
they can't even talk
like try to um get like a star or
anything like that
until it's either an option agreement or
sale
so yeah and where does one
submit for these optioning opportunities
um so there's lots of ways to do that um
there's a bunch of websites that have
producers that are looking for specific
stuff that you can pitch things to
uh like there's inktip isa
screenwriting staffing mandy used to but
i think they kind of backed off on doing
um script stuff i think it's mostly
actors now for mandy
um but they're like you know you pay a
certain amount of money
um either like every month or every
quarter uh
to basically get a newsletter from them
of producers that are looking for
specific things then you pitch your
stuff to them and then
if they dig it then they'll option it or
buy it and if not then they say thanks
for no thanks
um you can pitch stuff
in query letters uh we'll query emails
mostly now um you get like an imdb pro
account
you can gain access to uh not all of
them but
a large amount of industry people you
can get like their email or phone number
at least
where they work you know like if you
want to go after like a rep you know
like if you want to go like to
you know like ata or something you know
you can get the in contact information
for the company
producers a lot of times the producers
will have like uh contact for their
production company and then they might
even have uh their own personal
contact on there um so you send them
query letters and it's the same sort of
thing
you know if they like it great if not oh
well um
meeting people in person doing
networking um you know i've
one of my things that i i optioned was
through a craigslist ad so there's lots
of different avenues to find the
producers
you know to get your stuff out there
yeah i always say craigslist can be like
the most amazing experience or horrific
yeah it's just it's
a lot of people trash craigslist
because there's so many scams on
craigslist
you know there's a lot of things out
there that that but as long as you're
investing great stuff yeah
yeah i you know i've i have a producer i
met on there who has now hired me to
write like seven
short films um only two of them got
produced that i know of
um but you know i would it and you know
because it's a short there's not a whole
lot of money but it's like that's
stuff i can pump out in a day basically
you know to write like a little five
page
thing for him you know and make a little
cash to you know
pay for gas that week
[Laughter]
um and then like it's also as long as
you're vetting the people you know
making sure that they're not some like
schmuck who's like
oh yeah i'm gonna make a movie you know
uh imdb
whether you have the pro version or if
you're just imdb someone you can still
find out like what they've done
um google of course you can just google
people
um look them up on you know like do like
a search form on like
variety or deadline or anything like
that you know you can find out if they
have a track record of any kind
or if there's somebody making their very
first script or movie and even if they
are making a very smooth doesn't
necessarily mean they're going to scam
you
it means they haven't done anything yet
you know and and those can be very good
relationships too you know um you get in
with somebody who it's their very first
script
that they're going to be producing they
may not have
the budget to do like some big sale and
big production movie and stuff
but you get in it's still a produced
credit which
is much better than not having a reduced
credit even if it's a terrible movie
having that credit is is more useful to
you than
like just holding on to your babies and
not you know selling your stuff or
shopping your stuff around
and i always find too if the urgency of
how fast somebody wants you to do
something
if it's like it's got to be now or never
that's a red flag
yeah sure um i mean i get
things move quickly but if you're
getting like a weird feeling and they're
talking in circles
sometimes that's yeah there's definitely
people are doing the fake until you make
it sort of
stuff um when i was still living in
michigan i'm not going to name my names
but when i was living in michigan there
was a producer who
was had that sort of thing we're like oh
we have to sign this now now now
and it just wasn't a good deal and they
were gonna
like get way more out of it than i ever
would have you know and
they hadn't done anything and they were
like i don't even know if some of the
things they were saying are true or not
but like they are making like landish
claims you know
like the outlandish claims of who they
had deals with
you know of like distributor companies
and stuff that they already have like
first look deals with and stuff like
that which
may have been true never know but it's
one of those things that like it didn't
seem true
and when i looked them up there was
nothing to support their claims
that's a big one right it doesn't
necessarily mean it wasn't true because
like i was mentioning before the cameras
were rolling you know like there's a
writer that i know
who he makes like 300 grand
per draft but if you're looking on
binary he only has two produced credits
but he's written on like hundreds of
things
you know it's or or carrie fisher you
know she
you know if you looked up on anybody you
see all her acting stuff you'd only see
any writing stuff but she was like one
of the biggest
you know ghost writers in town you know
being paid to like do
touch-ups and stuff and she was getting
paid very well to fix these scripts you
know but you would never know it by
looking up on imdb you know so
people could make claims that are
totally true and you just can't find any
information on it but
if you can't find information on it
probably not
right but then like you said then the
urgency and then if it's
if it's like confusing and it shouldn't
be confusing yeah be looking at the
deals and have a lawyer look at the
deals too
um you can like attorneys
if it's an attorney that if you if you
think you're going to have a long
relationship with the attorney you can
probably convince them to do a
percentage deal as opposed to paying
them hourly that's what i have with my
attorney who does all my contracts i've
been with him since 2013 now
and he gets you know a percentage of
anything i make from any of these deals
which for him could be a ton of money if
i hit something big you know
if i were to sell my james hook script
to like warner brothers and get paid
like a million bucks and his five
percent of that million bucks is
a crapload of money whereas if nothing
happens he doesn't get any money so it's
kind of like a risk on his part too but
one that he was willing to make
because he saw potential of having deals
in the future
and you know i at this point i'm like i
i want i need one of those big deals so
i can give him
his five percent can be more money than
you know paying his rent for a month or
something you know
so like the man deserves to live wealthy
you know because he does such he busts
his butt you know to
to get me good deals and make sure that
i don't sign anything that is
not signable so um habit attorneys are
indispensable even if you get
even if you have to pay one hourly you
know
if you're gonna make it have a deal that
you're gonna make
a few thousand bucks on or something
like that it might be worth it to pay
somebody like a hundred bucks an hour to
look this over make sure that you're not
signing your soul away for pennies you
know
right 100 bucks an hour that's how
inexpensive oh
um i yeah i i've seen
most so if you get like an entertainment
lawyer there they could be as low as 100
bucks an hour
they could be as high as 500 bucks an
hour it kind of depends you kind of got
shop around just like you would
you know with any rep um or like i said
my guy i know my guy if i didn't have
his five percent
his rate's 130 an hour which is still
not bad when
you know most of these things or
whatever but the thing is though
you you can't really pressure him into
doing everything one hour you know
like you send them like an 11 page uh
contract
you know you're not gonna get even if
it's a hundred bucks an hour you're not
you're
paying at least 300 bucks i guarantee it
you know so um it's one of those things
you just kind of got to wait you know if
it's going to be like a little
dollar option thing maybe not but
um yeah lawyers are indispensable
because they're the ones who are going
to find all the stuff that
is a big red flag that you would never
know because all this legalese
it talks in circles i i understand some
of it now that i've had enough contracts
over the years
um so i know things to look out for but
there's still stuff that
my attorney and their attorney will will
be
having red lines back and forth that i
have no idea why this is a bad thing and
why
why i shouldn't sign but if my
attorney's saying no then no
and it's harder now because you know
before
late 2013 or late or early 2014 they
changed the laws a little bit
um with what attorneys can even do
for you because it used to be my lawyer
was able to
talk directly to the producers you know
on these deals and they could just
discuss the contract
between themselves i could just sit back
let them do their job
um but then the law changed like says
i can't remember end of 2013 began 2014.
where now he can't
uh he he can be the he can do all the
redlining on the contract but he's not
even allowed to
have to take a phone call with the
producer that i'm that i'm working on
because it'll count as him
doing an agent's work at that point okay
um
it's all like i i have a deal right now
that the the
producer isn't really understanding that
he's getting very angry that you know my
my attorney won't talk about it's like
it's not he won't talk to you he can't
legally talk to you you know and you
know it's one of those things that he
could
he could talk to you and like risk
everything by doing this just like you
know if you're
talking on the cell phone while you're
driving you're making a risk that you're
going to get arrested for that you know
or
pay a bill uh uh you know it's one of
those things you kind of gotta weigh
your risk options and my attorney will
not
you know cross that boundary just in
case kind of thing
travis i'm wondering if we can talk
about the levels of dimension
in a character so if we could talk about
what a three-dimensional character looks
like
and then one that's two-dimensional and
finally just a one-dimensional character
so how does one look flat versus a fully
fleshed out maybe three-dimensional
character not sure how to do
2d that's a interesting concept 1d in 3d
makes sense to me 2d
i created that yeah okay
[Laughter]
uh like i guess 2d is 100 piece of paper
so there's that
um so one uh so a single-dimensional
character somebody was just kind of
there
to facilitate the plot um
like they're there to basically just be
a moving piece along the way
um where they're just an anchor for the
story
um they're usually somebody who the
story is happening too
and they're not really making any
choices they're just kind of being
pushed along by
all the stuff that's occurring around
them um
three-dimensional character is more like
a real human being who makes choices and
some of those choices are good and some
of those choices are bad
um they're somebody who actually at
least makes decisions about the things
you know they're not somebody who
is being pushed along by
like if the killer's running after them
they're not just going
upstairs because that's where the story
needs to take place you know there's
somebody who
might fight back against the the bad guy
you know
um or somebody who may go and cower in a
closet somewhere you know it's very
character specific um you know somebody
who
may have a different experience you know
like
uh have like the exact same story you
have the main character
be a hairdresser they're going to make
way different decisions than
a character who's an fbi agent and that
would be a three-dimensional
character because they're all the
choices of of what they're doing
has to do with their experiences 1d
character would be somebody who we don't
if it was an fbi agent or a
beauty salon person it doesn't matter
because they're just going where the
story's going you know so
um yeah that's my best again 2d
is a piece of paper i don't know what to
do with that for a character
or maybe they're an fbi agent that has a
cover
as a hair salon and then these women can
find all these
things and they're like oh and then they
get these tips
are there different tests though that
you when you look at the characters that
you're writing and you say you know what
this is too
this is too one-dimensional right here
um
well i i try to come up with so i
i'm i'm personally more of a plot
writer than a character writer but even
in having a plot you need the characters
to make sense
i'm not going to make i still need to
find the
character to have in this place like if
i want an alien invasion story
i am not going to write a character that
could be
anything just because all i care about
is the cool explosions of having an
alien invasion happen
and so i have i need to find i need to
find characters that are gonna
make cool decisions that are cinematic
based on what's happening to them
so if i want something that's gonna be
like high
impact action where like the good guy is
fighting back i might have a soldier
as as the lead character and they're
going to make way different decisions
than like just the general public is you
know so
they're going to be helping other people
get out of the situation they're going
to be fighting back against the aliens
they're going to be
plotting and scheming and coming up with
whatever they can to survive
help others survive and defeat the bad
guy whereas if i want something that's
just
a terror driven thing where we
are like on the edge of our seats of oh
my god when is this person going to die
i might have just a regular joe schmoe
who has no experience
they're just looking out for themself
maybe not helping other people unless
they can't help it
um you know who's going to be cowering
in their car
and they are probably going to die at
any point
where so at that point it's like oh when
is this person going to die
versus the soldier oh when is he going
to beat the aliens
you know and because it's the same setup
because it's a different character it's
the same
it's a completely different story now um
so it's kind of one of those things of
like okay if i
i want this story to be about a specific
to go a certain route
i need to find the character that helps
that route along
and isn't just some random person you
know based on what the experience are
and even then my story because again i'm
outlining right so
in the outline i'm coming up with okay
what character would best facilitate now
i have to think
well what decisions is this character
going to make and how does that change
the rest of the plot that i
originally had in mind and so going from
my initial
like one sentence thing that i write my
idea book maybe a completely different
animal now that i have
the character for it um
[Music]
yes with your script if we go back to
2005 which you said was loosely based on
you or it was really yours
right it was a loosely based thing like
their thing the character was going
through the same
stuff that i was going through um
sometimes a little more dramatic
than what my own stuff was uh and
a vastly different outcome from what my
personal experience was
uh but yeah like that script was loosely
based on the the situation i was in
do you feel that that character was
three-dimensional or do you feel like
the writing i feel like that character
was
me uh in a sense and me kind of living
out
my own fantasy of how i like what i feel
like i should have done
the first two-thirds of that script was
the character was as weak as i was in
this situation um where it was
he was letting the stuff happen to him
and not really fighting back
and i felt like the stuff i was writing
was basically like
how i wanted to get out of that
situation but i in real life i was just
too like weak to do it
like i knew what needed to be done i
just couldn't convince myself to
actually do it
so i had the character who had the same
situation as me
and he was just as weak as i was until
he finally found the strength to push
forward and do what needed to be done
uh and even then like once i wrote that
point that was when i was able to like
end
that scenario in my own life um
it was it was a i was in an abusive
relationship is what that was and so
you know it was almost like a reverse
lifetime movie
you know there's a lot of lifetime
movies where like you got the the woman
who's being beaten by the man and stuff
you know and following her trail
so it was the guy being beaten by his
wife at the time you know and so
i you know in real life like i couldn't
get myself to get out of that situation
oh i don't want to cry i'm sorry oh i'm
sorry oh i feel bad now
no worries um so like i knew that i
needed to get out of the situation but i
just
couldn't get myself to do it you know
because i i was like low self-esteem at
the time so i felt like i couldn't do
any better
than than that and uh so
in the writing he you know rose above it
i'm sorry oh
okay so he in the story you know like
found the power that i couldn't
basically and rose above it and then
had like a much much different ending
obviously than just
leaving leaving it because i know i
wanted to be like kind of cinematic too
so there was like some
thrillery stuff thrown into the third
act of that um
that obviously never happened in real
life but it was the same
situation the same sort of feelings and
it was kind of like so that's why was it
like therapy for me yeah
to get out of it okay
what is connectivity in a screenplay and
why is that important
i feel like that to me at least the
connectivity seems like it would go with
uh like plot holes
sort of thing like filling it because uh
a lot of new writers
when they're writing stuff aren't really
looking at it as a whole they're just
doing like scene by scene by scene by
scene racing and not realizing when
there are things that happen here
that you never set up over here so it
kind of feels like it's out of left
field you know like the
the the big thing is having like you
know twist endings and stuff like that
well twist ending doesn't work if you
didn't set it up
in in advance uh it'll just feel
completely out of left field
you know so it to me at least
that's my understanding of from the
question you know with that is
is being able to connect the different
aspects of the thing to
make it make sense because if you don't
have the setup
then the payoff doesn't work you know or
if you do a setup and then there's no
payoff well now you just
ruin the perfectly good setup and people
are going to be mad why didn't
this come to fruition you know right
okay so so
just like turn of events different
things it can't just happen where there
was nothing
to set something off yeah like i said
the twist doesn't work if there's no no
setup if otherwise it's just a twist for
the sake of having a twist
and that never works well right do you
think that it's best though that the
audience didn't see the twist coming i
mean in terms of
the audience likes to know something
sure they told him even even in a movie
where there's like a twist that you
never saw coming there's usually
something in it
that if you were to go rewind it and
watch it again like then you'll see
oh that was already set up in advance
sort of thing you know
i feel like in a movie if it's going
forward
and then the ending like is completely
bizarro and had nothing to do with
anything like i feel like i'm cheated
that feels like a huge like deus ex
machina sort of situation to me of like
there's no way this would have happened
why did this suddenly happen you know
but if there's things that set up i just
read so i i read through a lot of the
like the blacklist
scripts and i just read one that was on
2019 blacklist
where the ending is kind of a twist
ending but it's something that that
if you paid attention got set up a few
pages at least prior so it wasn't like
way at the beginning it got set up but
um and like the twist ending
in it was that it's about a mountain
climber who she's climbing up this
mountain and it's like haunted mountain
and and at the very end of it i don't
know if there's gonna be a spoiler
because i don't as far as i know it
hasn't got picked up anywhere yet so in
five years from now it may be picked up
and i apologize for spoiling it five
years in advance
um but she gets at the end like as she's
climbing
um when she gets to the very tip top it
turns out that now she's
like a part of like a heavenly sort of
situation and then it
suddenly jumps to where find her dead
body like in the cave below
um and it's kind of twisty because it's
like also okay she got the claw
what she was dead but it sets it up
because there's a couple different times
when she falls while climbing the
mountain and like
miraculously got saved especially the
very last one when she falls and one of
the ghosts
catch her is like at that point okay
she's still plummeting
when he caught her but it makes it look
like or um what's the one with mandy
moore in the sharks
uh oh 457 meters yeah let's try that
again
right so 47 meters with mandy moore you
know like the
and i apologize again for spoiling stuff
but at the end of the thing you find out
that like a lot of
the rest of the a lot of the end of the
script like never happened like she gets
saved
and we find out that oh she's actually
been imagining this whole thing
the whole time about her having this
final encounter with the shark
getting out of the cage getting rescued
coming up on the ship
and then do a really cool way you know
she had gotten like injured along the
way and when she's on the ship
her blood is like floating in the air
above her and she's like watching it
and then it cuts down to her still being
in the shark tank
and but they set that up it because of
the whole thing of
of um like hypoxia and and in
running out of oxygen so you know it
starts to like mess your head
hallucinating and stuff
that was one of the first things they
talked about in the movie you know it
was like the dangers of being
at such a low depth you know of if you
can't come if you don't come back up
in time and they even talked about it
again while she was in the tank with her
sister before her sister like got killed
and stuff
by the shark that they were discussing
it again so it's like it's something got
set up twice
before we saw the ending so some people
you know watching and stuff like what
she
imagined that that's a horrible but no
it wasn't because they set it up
twice before then so we kind of saw that
it
was a possibility of her hallucinating
so that sets up
oh if she could hallucinate then yes
that makes sense for hallucinous ending
it kind of infuriates the audience still
because oh i wanted her to survive and
she's not gonna
but it sets it up so the twist works did
you see
strange but true with margaret quality i
don't believe so
it's an adaptation i think it came out
last year and that one
was a shocker and then when you write
when you go back there were a few clues
yeah
i don't want to give i mean such a great
film um
it was like a dark well you know the one
that everyone keeps go always goes to
with the twist ending you know
is uh sixth sense like if you paid
attention you could
find that you could figure out you know
or if even if you didn't figure out if
you rewind it watch the second time
you'll find all the different clues
along the way that bruce willis is a
ghost the whole time you know
um there's it's a lot of like little
minor things
the you i didn't catch it the first time
i watched it most people didn't
and people were like what that doesn't
make sense i rewatched a second time
like oh
here's where it's set up for it here's
where it's set up for it here's
here's two scenes in a row where it sets
up for it so you know
it worked because there were setups like
you don't you didn't realize it along
the way but then
it's one of those things that like you
look back on it and find out the movie
was much better
than you actually realized that while
you were watching it sort of thing
yeah you like m.9 oh yeah i
m a lot of people give him for some
of those yeah i don't know why but
um the only movie of his i didn't like
was the happening
uh with the one where the trees are
killing everyone okay that was the only
one that i thought was like two out
there
um but like i i'm a huge fan of his
stuff i
i really want to see the servant on
apple tv plus i haven't gotten a chance
to watch it yet
there's i actually want to see most of
the shows in apple tv plus i'm just like
itching to to to watch those um put it
on the vision board yeah
basically not another what seven eight
bucks a month or whatever it is
i know but no this vision board idea is
getting expensive now all right
you don't have the coffee expense right
yeah
that adds up so so your book 365
a year of screenwriting tips which is
beautifully displayed
behind us and then you also have a copy
there now i think you said
first off to begin the purpose of the
book is not to try and make
you better at a specific thing right um
so a lot of screenwriting books will
focus on one specific thing
you know um there's a book uh
what is it shadow something uh
it's a very good book i can't remember
what it's called the plug it for him um
but it's it's all about characters and
how to write characters specifically
villainous characters um then you have
you know like blake snyder's you know
save the cat that everyone loves and
stuff that tells you like how to outline
a story basically and like how
story beats work and then you have
you know books that are like either like
specifically about
television writing stephen l sears a
prolific tv
writer he he was the executive producer
on xena warrior princess
and he's got a book that's just about tv
writing and
it covers you know like how to come up
with ideas and also some of the business
stuff which is why it's a very good book
because it
goes over the business stuff that a lot
of other things skip
and pass on and so my book has like it's
not about
a specific thing it's kind of like a
general overall arc
of writing um the process of writing the
business of writing what you can expect
um you know i've got it broken down into
different parts if i can
get to the table of contents so we've
got like the before you start which is
you know talking about
um some of the misconceptions about
writing in general
uh it talks about you know like you said
before about like the the
statistic that there are nfl football
players and there are screen writers
uh then there's like a bit on writing
and there's prep work uh which is you
know about outlining and
and treatments and how to come up with
ideas uh
there's a section on format so instead
of being a whole book about format
you've got one section here that's what
uh
40ish pages on formatting and each of
the
each of the things are only like a page
or less each you know so
um it's all very quick reading um
there's a thing specifically on story
thinking characters dialogue thing on
rewriting and then after what to do
after the script is done and
there's so it covers a little bit on
everything but it's not
it's not made to make you a better
writer it's more of
to know about the writing process what
to do before and after
how to get your head in game and come up
with ideas and stuff like that
it also has ideas on how to relax um you
know i've got in there
one of the tips is about having a
positivity calendar because it is very
difficult to stay positive
in this industry when you're getting
rejections coming at you from everywhere
um so my positivity calendar is is you
get your calendar instead of checking
the calendar off with
x's like they do in the movies uh i mark
off the days in the calendar by writing
every positive thing that happened to me
that day
oh that's great so then later on if i
have like a really bad rejection
or like really wanting this meeting and
then it fell through
instead of being like being alone i can
look back at the calendar oh
well okay yes today didn't wasn't so
great but look at all this amazing stuff
that happened to me
earlier on in the week and stuff you
know or and yeah it's a good way to keep
kept track of your progress like i also
put in there like
my pa what page i ended on on my
different on my scripts each day so then
i can also keep track of my progress
like that's a positive thing i i got
yesterday i was on page 23 today on page
34. awesome i wrote you know
a bunch of pages today you know and
another tip in there
is uh relax go if you're in los angeles
go to salt and straw get yourself some
ice cream because it's fantastic ice
cream
i know where's that by the way they have
a bunch of locations
um they're originally from oregon i
believe um and then they've
they've got uh in portland they've got
like a couple locations and now here in
la they've got i think
five locations in la there's one on
third street in downtown
uh the only reason i don't suggest
something else is nowhere to park in
in the arts district um there's one on
larchmont
there's one on ventura uh like up in
in noho area um there's one in uh
venice um there's one on
santa monica boulevard uh there's one
uh in um downtown disney now oh no just
opened uh
last year i think and then they've got a
couple locations i think
the one location two locations down in
san diego so like all along
the west coast they've got salt and
straw and they're oh san francisco they
just opened a san francisco one too so
basically everywhere along the west
coast uh
it's fantastic ice cream and they change
their flavors every month they
they have some really good fun they have
some really bizarre ones too like uh
in april last april for the spring i
think they had one that had
chocolate covered bugs in it oh wow it
was a grass flavored
ice cream with chocolate covered bugs um
for halloween they
had a blood pudding one that the main
base actually was chicken blood and
livers
yeah but then they also have you know
like they all they have regular flavors
too
okay do they have they have chunky they
have like chocolate stuff
you know and they have um like right now
for february they have
you know a chocolatier series where all
the flavors are
based on like a local chocolatier
company like
if you're in la it's like all la
chocolate companies
um you know like like the comparte and
um
31 blackbirds and stuff like that where
they make the ice cream based on those
san diego
portland they all have like their own
local chocolatiers that they change
their
their recipes for so uh one year they
had um
i don't know why i'm talking about ice
cream now so screen rating i'm sorry
very hungry
i'm sorry
i want to actually go into some of the
the tips that you have
one of the first ones is um regarding
cliches so i'm curious
what is one of the most cliche pieces of
screenwriting devices actually
absolutely true and then vice versa
most cliche piece of screenwriting
advice
that is false
okay so cliche that is absolutely
writing is rewriting or something
sure you know um
let me think about that for a second uh
one that's true and one that's false so
a
true cliche in my opinion
i would say is that you should write
every day um
because if you get in the habit of not
writing then you're going to stay in the
habit of not writing
if you get the habit of writing you're
going to keep writing
um if you're in this
to be like if you want to take time off
everyone needs time off
you're going to burn yourself out if you
if you write like
and never have fun you know so you still
gotta you still gotta take time
but if you're not writing every day then
you're not getting in the habit of
writing and it's way too
easy to just sit back and go watch shows
instead of writing your own show and
then you don't get stuff done and that's
why it takes
people they've been writing the same
script for the last two years
you know and they're not even close to
done with it yet you know like oh yeah i
got the first act on
really in in two years um
or they've written just one script and
then never anymore and they're just
shopping on the same script for five
years and haven't don't have any
additional
stuff so button the seat is a must
uh that i think is absolutely true uh
one that i think is absolutely
not true is
um that you have to have everything
format perfect there are certain things
that you do need to have it needs to
look like a screenplay so if you turn
something that looks like a novel
it's gonna get thrown in the trash um
there are certain components that it
needs to have it needs to have dialogue
it needs to have
unless it's a silent film um it also
needs to have description and it should
look about the same
but nobody's gonna fault you
if like you have one too many lines in
your description
uh so like the thing even in my book i
mentioned that you should try to have
four lines or less in your description
paragraphs nobody's gonna fall at you if
it's five lines they're not gonna be
like oh this one paragraph is fine no
not can't do it um typos
are one that i would say you absolutely
should fix if you can
but there are plenty of professional
writers who have the occasional typo so
they're not going to throw it in the
garbage the first type of they see
unless the table is on page one then
they're probably gonna throw it in the
garbage immediately
um so yeah i would say
that the formatting can't oh and then
like bolding or not bolding your slug
lines is another formatting thing where
people are like oh if you
like nobody like you can't bold your
your slug lines
yes you can you can't underline your
slug lines yes you can
they're not gonna throw it away as long
as the story is good they're gonna
forgive you like minor faux pas or
alterations of the formatting
um so they're not going to be like oh
this is not written correctly they will
do it if it looks nothing like a script
though i will say that
if it doesn't even look like a
screenplay then they'll throw it away
but even even things like page length is
is
there's some give you know if it you
know i've heard that if it's
not 90 pages 120 pages if it's less than
90 or more 120 it'll get thrown away
that's not true
if it's 120 to 123 pages i won't have
fun reading it
but i'm not going to throw it in the
garbage you know if a producer
if i think it's good enough story you
know for a producer because i do reading
on the side too as one of my
side gigs and stuff for like producers
and for contests and stuff you know
um yeah okay again i feel like i talked
way too long no no i like that okay so
um those are the two one that's a cliche
that that is true
and one that's a cliche uh that maybe
there's some give on
tip number one experts are liars yeah so
a lot of screenwriting books i feel
are there to sell screenwriting books
and one of the first things i say in my
book is that i'm not a guru or an expert
of any kind
you know i here's what i've done here's
what i haven't done
i'm not going to lie to you and say i
know the answers a lot of screenwriting
gurus will tell you like
this is the way it needs to be done
that's why i'm writing this book so that
you do it right
there are so many ways in this industry
to to be a writer like i said some
people outline some people don't
um some people follow
different methodologies of storytelling
you know like some people may follow
blake snyder's beat sheet some people
may follow
the the hero's journey they're very
similar things but they're different i
even in the book i talk about like five
or six different
methods of storytelling even i'm not
saying one is better than the other and
that you need to write this way i'm
saying here are the options
for you you know what are they uh let me
just case that's
that's fine if you can pause the tape oh
sure sure yeah find it
uh let's see 134 is where story starts
it's probably around there again i don't
know my
i don't have everything memorized
i'll see five types of conflict there's
okay so we got aristotle's version uh
we got the blake lake uh snyder's save
the cat beat sheet
heroes journey sid field's paradigm
uh the five act structure the four act
structure because usually you've got
three act structure and stuff well these
guys are telling you there are more
structures you can do than just three
act we got the mini movie method
uh we got max landis's rule of three uh
you know so it's like there's that's
what one two
three four five six seven eight
different versions of storytelling that
i
talk about here there might even be more
later on if i messed up on how i
numbered my tips in here that's
excellent but uh yeah
so which do you prefer when you're
writing
i honestly don't use any of them i just
write a story
like i said i'm outlining like crazy and
then revising my outline until i get a
bulletproof story
so i'm not really going with you know
any of these specific things
like we got the blake snyder you got you
know your opening image set up
stated state your theme then the
catalyst the debate the breaking act two
i don't really think about any of that
when i'm doing act one i'm just starting
with okay
how does this how does the world open so
that we can know who the character we're
going to follow is and what's going to
happen in this story
i feel like you the one thing is that by
the end of act 1 we should know what the
story is going to be about
but i'm not going to break it down
because i i believe in blake snare's
book he actually gives you even specific
page
page numbers of where the thing should
happen by i'm like that's way by the
numbers like
there's i it takes away too much
creativity i feel if you're gonna be
like
that the the exception i would say is in
television writing
because you've got to go to the
commercials
um if you're on if you're on like a
broadcasting like nbc or something but
versus streaming um that you need to
have
like each act end with some kind of
cliffhanger
to bring the audience back after the
commercial break um
and you need to do we need if you're
good
i would say your a story and b story you
should have them in certain spots so
that it it flows throughout the thing
but for feature writing i don't know
that any of these are necessarily needed
to be in any specific order or
by a certain page count as long as
they're there
um because you know you look at
forrest gump it you can if you look at
forrest gump it's act one is like
five minutes tops and then the rest of
it's in act two for the most part you
know and then act three is like that
you know whereas whereas some methods
tell you that like act one should be
ending on like between page 25 and 30
well
forrest gump quelled that didn't it you
know exactly one is
up until he's an adult and then suddenly
he's going off to war
and like now we're already in act two
and we're only like five to ten minutes
into the movie tops
you know right but do you think for a
newbie screenwriter because you know i'm
thinking about like a chef and i
remember i saw the professional a
professional shop another
job i've had by the way oh you have i
was a sous chef once oh nice
okay so you're used to conflict and
being under stress
and i've done everything so so and i
asked the chef do you measure and the
the chef scoffed and said no that's for
amateurs or whatever
and but you think that after a while
then you don't need to say
sure by this page there's going to be
this plot point
you know well okay so i feel like it's a
little bit different though because i
will absolutely agree with the chef
thing because if i'm cooking something
for the very first time as a recipe i've
never used before i'm gonna follow the
recipe to the thing
but then once i know what it's supposed
to look like and tastes like i can just
start
eyeballing it you know my mom has not
used her measuring cup since
probably the day i was born um she just
kind of like
okay the recipe calls for a cup that's
about a cup there we go boom
you know um you just kind of go by taste
that point but um
and i would say doing by taste is is a
good
phrase to use for for the script and
stuff is that
these are all the guidelines but it you
know if you
if you change your mac and cheese recipe
a little bit it's
still a damn good mac and cheese just
not the same mac and cheese that this
person made
and so it's you know you're do it you
know so it's the same thing with the
scripts like these are your outlines of
of how of the general story right so
like the hero's journey you know you've
got like your epic adventure here
here's how it would look but if you
tweak some stuff along the way
tell a different story it's not better
or worse than what he's got it's a
different story you know
um and it might be better if the
ingredients you use
fit the bill you know so um these are
good things to know
as the guidelines which is why i
mentioned so many of them so you can see
okay this is what all the experts are
saying
take those and work with them how you
want maybe take a little bit from this
pile a little bit from this pile and
tell the stories you want to tell
in the best way you can figure out how
to tell it
tip number two okay so tip number two
there are only two screenwriting rules
yeah
the so i've got my book here i've even
got them labeled for you
rule number one is write a script that
looks like a script
which i already talked about right so if
it looks like a novel
it's not a script it's going in the
garbage so if it looks like a script
you've
or at least got past the first gate
because there are a lot of scripts that
come in
that don't look like scripts they're
getting like i
seriously when i was uh doing reading
for a producer
i was sent the script to read that was
312 pages
i'm not reading a 312 page script it's
not happening
so it doesn't look like a script right
off the bat so as long as it looks like
a script
like i said even the formatting you can
have little tweaks here and there as
long as it
still looks like a script and number two
write a script that feels like a movie
preferably a good movie
if you're obviously wearing tv then it
would be right if it feels like a tv
episode
if you are writing this big lengthy
thing that
feels like it should be a novel you're
getting into characters minds
all this other stuff it's not a movie
anymore if you're telling me something
that's
just us sitting here having a
conversation this is great for a youtube
video
i'm not going to watch a whole movie of
me sitting here talking to you like even
documentaries you they're cutting away
to other stuff
right like other things are happening
they're just two people talking to each
other so it needs to
look like a movie look like a script and
it needs to feel like a movie
bonus points if it's a good movie like
that okay so don't
write war and peace oh yeah and submit
it
yeah and don't don't try to have an
eight-part series
yeah because if it's if it's a short so
i've been asked a question from people
on like facebook and stuff where they've
dm'd me and asking like okay how do you
how can i tell if it's a short or a
feature or show
okay if you can tell the entire story in
like
20 minutes or less and be done with it
it's a short
if you can tell the thing if it's gonna
take at least half an hour to tell it
and you can have it done in like three
hours and then that's it like we never
have to see these characters again like
it's a feature
if it's too short flesh it out to
feature to to get there
if it's you know like a little bit if
it's three hours try to pull back a
little bit to make it a feature
but it's a feature if you can tell it
you know in a couple of hours but if
it's something that could go on and on
forever it's probably a television
series
um you know if if i made a flash like if
i'm going to comic books if i
have the flash tv series versus the
the flash movie that may or may not ever
even happen now
with with uh ezra miller um
those are gonna be two very different
flash stories because in one
they're gonna be telling the story
between like an hour and a half two and
a half hours
the other one we're already what six
seasons in and it's still going we can
have episodic
and keep going you know um they're gonna
be two very different
stories to tell sort of thing so
yes that is so that's that's the thing
with the with it being cinematic is
figuring out where does it fall in line
is it a short is it a feature is it a tv
show
is it a book is it like a is it a comic
book series
is it a poem you know all these
different things have
different uh sort of world and
guidelines
to them because of your story but it
needs it needs to go around the story
you want to tell
so if the story you want to tell if you
could keep telling it over and over and
over with different things
it's probably a tv series if you're
going to tell me this succinct little
story that's cool and has like a couple
different a plot people out the c
plot but it's only going to take you two
hours to tell it
it's a feature so keeping those in mind
is how to figure out
you know where your story lies among
all of the medium that there is to
create in
it might be a painting i don't know
exactly you cannot trash talk the field
you want to be a part of
yes uh so this is one of the things
so a big reason i wrote this book to
begin with was because of seeing people
on
the facebook screenwriting groups asking
the same questions over and over
this particular tip was seeing of huge
faux pas that a lot of
writers do where they're like i'm
writing this because there's nothing
good in hollywood
there are no good movies anymore well
why are if you're announcing that to the
world like why do you want to make
movies
if there's nothing good like what is the
point of you
going into a field where you think
everything out there is garbage why
do you want to be a part of this and why
are you going to tell people that you
think it's all garbage to begin with you
know
it's so yeah don't don't trash this is
the field you want to be in don't start
trash talking other people's work
don't trust talk other people who are
working in the industry that you may or
may not ever work with
because this is a small town and that
gets around
so safer for politics oh yeah
[Laughter]
what is screenwriter homework and can
you give me an assignment
so your homework can give you an
assignment all right so the homework is
doing the work
first off uh but let's go with a
specific assignment for you
um you want to come up with an idea for
a story um but you don't really know
where to start so one good place to
start that i have in my book
is the comp game so
for those who don't know what a comp is
a comp is this meets that
you know so like a movie is harry meets
sally
meets air bud what is that movie gonna
be
so there's your assignment you come up
with and this is a um
since my fiance is sitting here i'll
tell this story okay uh
so a script i have out uh that i'm
passing on is called run
uh it is a story about a detective who
is being forced to
run non-stop uh in order to save her
daughter from a killer
um my placed in several contests
at this point i've been semi-finalist uh
in in like three of them and
quarterfinalists another two um and it's
a script that like a lot of people seem
to like um
where did that story come from okay so
we were playing the comp game one day
driving to a networking event stuck in
traffic
so we were playing cop game coming up
with i was coming with
bizarre things she was kind of bizarre
things i think at one point i told her
she needed to do
i might have actually said airbud meets
something else so she gave me
okay saw meets speed
okay so i'm like okay so speed is
you know the dude in the bus that can't
slow down or it's going to blow up
saw is this killer guy who has these
people and making them do obstacles to
save their own lives so i mesh them
together
i now have a woman who can't stop
running or her daughter will die and she
has to
along with running has to do these
various like
uh feats that he makes her do and stuff
like oh she has to run
to this point in this amount of time and
go if you don't then your daughter's
friend who i also have kidnapped is
gonna die
so i'm combining those two things so
there's your homework
let's give you a like a couple of uh
comps or whatever to come up with so
okay so how about
16 candles meets home alone okay 16
candles in the home alone
so we're gonna take those two movies and
we're gonna merge together 16 candles
you got
a story about a girl who it's her
birthday and everyone seems to have
forgotten that it's her birthday
uh home alone is a guy who
his parents go on vacation and leave him
there awesome
all right so we've got kids home alone
it's his birthday all right so we've got
kid's birthday uh he wakes up nobody
remembers his birthday he goes off
he comes home to a house that is full of
stuff for a surprise party
but everyone else is gone they set up
and they left him alone so while he's at
the surprise party waiting around
his own party uh some people try to
break into his house
luckily he's got things already around
now that he can use to defend himself
he has a banner that he turns into a
giant slingshot to shoot the
bad guys across the street uh they come
in oh look here's birthday cake with
with uh trick candles on it so he lights
the trick candles now he's got
roman candle torch that he can use as
defense and shoot it off like a big
firework of people
uh and then the parents once he's
defeated the bad guys they come home
everybody comes home forgetting that
they set up for this birthday party
don't know why there's all this mess
here until the mom finds the uh
the banner at the end and then oh by the
way your birthday present
happens to be something he destroyed
while trying to do it
idea outside my head it probably sucks i
know it sucks but
there that's kind of what the comp game
is you come up with things they may not
be good
they may be amazing it's kind of a thing
of trying to figure out how to
meld the two things together because
there is i'm a firm believer that there
are no more original stories left to
tell
because we've been telling stories since
the dawn of time
the trick is to find new ways into the
stories
and the reason i have the comp game is a
fantastic way of doing that is taking
two stories that already exist and
finding where they
meet in the middle what is it the venn
diagram where they've got the circles
and
things over here so finding those things
is a great way to to create your own
story by melding
other stories already existing i'm just
going to be don't be super obvious about
it like i just was with this 16 candles
home alone
um like i said with the run i i knew it
had to be something that
couldn't stop moving from speed and
there had to be a serial killer
with obstacles like saw and so i created
a whole new character that went into
there
uh and how to mesh them together like
she's no longer on a bus now she's
running
you know so fine the the original idea
in them um another thing you can do is
coming up finding a movie you like but
that has ending
can i say i'm sorry i have a crappy
ending
um and uh tweak it to okay
how would you have ended this story can
you now write a story that
ends that way and has a different
beginning you know so
so you can always borrow from other
things like um
even and people borrowing even even uh
william shakespeare was borrowing people
you know
romeo and juliet was not an original
thing he stole romeo and juliet from
like a greek mythology thing and then
just
made his own tweaks to it you know so we
can make our own tweaks to everything so
your homework
is to find a story that already exists
find a way to spin it and make it a
completely new original story
okay argo and sleeping with the enemy
oh crap can we just cut i don't want to
do that anymore oh jeez
we could end it there okay sorry i just
wanted to
throw out that one okay now i'm
thinking about it though i'm thinking
about that that was just for fun no
we won't do that so somebody got
kidnapped and it was it turns out that
it was his
lover but in order in order to save his
lover he has to make a movie that
involves his lover
this actually sounds like a good one
okay
this is a fun game so it should be a
party game yeah you should i can see
michael's crafts
there's a similar party game
pitchstorm is similar that one it
doesn't do it doesn't do quite the same
thing it doesn't take movies
and make you combine them a pitch storm
is it's a card game where in each
on the cards they have different
elements like
a certain type of character and a
certain scenario
and you have to come up with the story
that uses that and you're pitching it
and then
um it has kind of like a an
apples-to-apples
component so there's a judge and the
judge is actually throwing out
things too they're actually being the
executive you know and so while you're
telling the story
at any point they can still be like oh
but what if and then they have an
executive card that has like some random
thing that they throw in there some note
that they're like oh what if
you know you're so i'm telling my story
of ron you know the the woman who's
let's say my thing was a detective and
and running and so like i'm telling the
story
okay so she's running and the detect or
the bad guy calls her and tells her she
has to get to this certain point
and he goes oh let me stop you what if
suddenly
aliens drop down so you know it's a
bizarre little game like that it's a
similar concept
but not quite the same i i've thought
about trying to to do that but i'm not
sure
i'm not sure what the legality would be
of
as far as the copywriting stuff you know
putting out a game where i'm where it's
like a bunch of movie things that you
haven't come out you can do it on your
own
so you know it's not really something
like phil needs to have it but i'm like
it could be like a extra thing to go
with the book i guess
yeah that's true of your 365
tips which is one or two that you have
the most trouble following
yourself that's tricky that's tricky
tricky tricky let's find out well okay
self-fulfilling prophecy tip number ten
that one my sister again my sister's
psychologist gets on me all the
time and stuff um can i actually just
read it or no sure please do all right
it actually starts with my little sister
psychologist see if she's the one who
inspired the
tip number ten self-fulfilling prophecy
my little sister is a psychologist
she loves to warn me against
self-fulfilling prophecies
what's that basically if you think
something will happen
it might happen but if you think
something won't happen it definitely
won't happen keeping a positive attitude
keeps you in a better mood
and ensures you're working towards
staying that way but
if you think negatively believe you're
going to fail
you will fail because you'll get it in
your head that you're going to fail
and you'll subconsciously keep yourself
in the failing mindset making it nearly
impossible to succeed
don't get yourself into a negative
self-fulfilling prophecy don't tweet it
don't say it don't even think it stay
positive
that is one i definitely have trouble
with because i'm
wanting to get meetings for these
awesome new shows coming out but
nobody's returning phone calls
or and so i'm like oh this is never
gonna especially when you're getting on
twitter and and facebook and you're
friends with people who already are
professional writers
you're hearing about all the cool shows
they're getting meetings for
or you're hearing about them having like
a sale meeting next week with abc to
sell their show to them
or they just got this really cool
assignment through crypt tv to write
a horror series for them that's all so
daunting when you're
trying to do it and not doing it so
vaughn i start saying oh
i'm never gonna get there because i
haven't gotten there yet
now i'm keeping myself in that mindset
i'm never gonna get there
and and keep failing and failing failing
whereas if i keep
that's fantastic for them i'm going to
get there really soon
you might actually get there really soon
now because now you're striving towards
it whereas as soon as i get the
depression of
i'm never going to get there well right
because now i'm going to stop doing
working as hard because
what's the point anymore right so that's
definitely a pitfall that i
have a problem with and she will tell
you that that's absolutely true we just
had this conversation last night
so that's one issue and that's a really
good one
yeah that was the first one that came to
mind about that um
let's see turn off facebook is tip 54.
procrastination much yes i do
um
let's see those are probably the two big
ones i have a problem with
okay those are good oh female
descriptions
i definitely accidentally at least on my
first drafts we'll definitely be using
things
talking about like how attractive
someone is and
it's not like stuff that flies anymore
especially when you're doing it only
with female characters and not with guys
like why is all your female characters
attractive females
but all your men are just who they are
you know
it seems a lot um i'll even and this
one's the short ones i'll even read this
one for you
beautiful gorgeous stunning sexy a
knockout
the kind of girl that is so hot that
would be so hot if she didn't have
makeup
do you see where i'm going with this
using these sorts of statements to
describe your character is boring and
flat and a bit sexist
even if it's not meant to be but there's
no normal girls in your script
they're just all gorgeous pieces of ass
huh but then the problem is
that a lot of writers will have those
descriptors for the women you know
they'll have like
debbie 34 hot blonde or
you know jessica age 26 is
an attract would be very attractive
without her glasses or something but
then the men
are dan 54 the kind of guy you don't
want to get in a fight with
how does that tell you what is about you
know you're using
looks of the girls but for guys you're
using personality traits why
you know so i i feel like i fall in that
especially in my first in my early
drafts like when i'm doing like a first
draft of the script
because i'm in my head like the first
thing comes to my mind is is
what type of person like what they look
like so i can figure out
who would play them because i like to
kind of sometimes cast in my head
so i can kind of think of mannerisms and
and that sort of thing
um so the first thing that comes to my
mind is is what they look like i feel
like a lot of writers probably have that
same issue but the problem is
we're only doing it for the women i'm
not i'm not telling you how ruggedly
handsome bill
is you know so what if it was a writer
that was attracted to bill
whether they were male or female and
they this is
what was visually appealing to them and
so if they were
at a coffee shop and they saw bill walk
by they would be like wow he is ruggedly
handsome
oh my goodness and whoever whoever the
writer's perspective is sure they're
just writing who they find each other i
think it comes
to not knowing your character well
enough yet because you're
just going on that initial instinct you
know if i see somebody at a party
i can see okay they're attractive or
they look like a freak
or whatever i don't know who they are
yet so i can't tell you oh
this is like somebody that you know
they're very soft-spoken
until you get on something that they're
passionate about because i don't know
that yet i'm just looking at them
so that might be an issue of like you're
writing the script and you're
not quite sure who the person is quite
yet especially not outlining
my but i outlined so my problem is just
that it's i'm going with the visual
first and and
worrying about character in like later
drafts because i'm
you know still telling i'm i know what
they're gonna do i just don't know who
they are yet sort of thing you know so
um so then for someone who's writing a
character that they are attracted
attracted to sure whatever the the
gender
um not focusing so much on looks
right because especially if you're not
doing it across the board if you're
telling
every person what every person looks
like that is one thing it's also going
to be a little boring
by telling what every single person
looks like i hate reading the scripts
what they're wearing
there are so many i've read so many
scripts where they tell me the costume
that they're wearing in every single
scene i don't need to know
we're blue jeans here but they were
khakis over here it's not important
it's not story right that's set dressing
and you know and
but so like if you're if you're going to
go and tell whatever you see even even
using ethnicities i feel like it falls
in the same category you know if you're
going to tell the ethnicity of every
single character
great but if you're assuming white and
you're just pointing out this person's
black
like that feels racist kind that's true
you know um like
so either across the board tell whoever
tell what everyone looks like
or across the board don't tell us what
everyone looks like and tell us who they
are
got it okay that makes sense i like that
i'm not sure which tip it is but let
people read your stuff
versus don't show your unfinished
manuscript to anyone
so i think the the trick there is the
unfinished
aspect everybody and this is another tip
that's in the book
that you probably hear frequently is
that the first draft of everything sucks
i don't care how good you are your first
draft is terrible compared to what you
can make it
so if it's unfinished it's already
don't show it to people because they're
gonna judge you based on what they've
read
so if the thing is not done yet don't
don't give it to people to put in their
eyes because
if it's not up to par that's all they're
gonna see is that you're a subpar
writer um
on the other side though of needing to
show your stuff once it's ready
get it out to the world i've met many
writers who are very precious about
their material
and they won't enter screenplay contests
because they're afraid that people are
going to steal it
which almost never actually happens
there are obviously a couple cases
like the whole thing with the matrix way
back when stuff that oh it was stolen
from i don't know if it's true or not
but there are there have probably been
like a couple of
thieveries along the way but it's very
infrequent because
it would cost the production companies
way less money to just buy your script
than it would to pay off a lawsuit
against them for stealing stuff
um but if you don't show your stuff out
there either whether it be out of fear
of them stealing it
or out of fear that it's not good enough
you'll never know if it could get sold
anywhere
if you if you're like oh well i don't
know if it's good enough i don't want to
show anyone because i'm
i'm nervous about the quality of it it
might not be good well then you're never
going to know if it's good enough
because nobody has been able to read it
to tell you if it's good enough
um so it absolutely needs to get out
there but not before it's ready
okay that's good have a laugh every 10
pages
a scare every 10 pages and action every
time sure so this goes with the
genres so that the trick of you know
if it's a comedy if it's supposed to be
a comedy and i'm reading it i'm 50 pages
in and i have not even smiled
probably not funny um so the trick is to
whatever your genre is for the script
have
an element of that genre like every 10
pages
um that way it keeps it fresh in your
head oh this is supposed to be scary
because this scary thing just happened
here and now it's happening again
um or comedy oh i just laughed you know
a couple pages ago
here's another joke okay this is clearly
a comedy because if you stretch out
using comedy as the best example if you
go too long and it's not funny that's a
drama
it's not a comedy anymore um or if if
you're writing a drama and
i don't care about anything that's
happening it's just boring
but if it's a horror and nothing scary
happens
how is that how is that a horror at that
point you know it might be a thriller
you know where because there's there's a
fine line going between thriller and
horror
uh but if it's if there's not scary
stuff happening
it's not a because it's not scary
so
yeah so the every 10 pages basically
just keeping that genre
continuing throughout the whole script
what's your favorite
tip of the 365 my favorite of the 65
uh
i would say let's see if i can find it
here
um
okay so i'm gonna say it's my favorite
because i think it's the one that gives
the most information it's actually
several tips in a row i'm just having
problem
figuring out where it is is actually
about writing will not make you rich
a lot of people seem to think that oh
i'm gonna sell my script quit my day job
i'm gonna be a screenwriter forever it's
gonna be awesome that's not the case
though if i can find
i think it's like three or four tips in
a row i can tell you
exactly why um but basically the money
that you think you're going to make is
not
all yours for starters because a you got
to think about taxes
you know depending on where you live
you're going to have federal taxes taken
out of it
state taxes taken out of it uh
self-employment tax taken out of it and
city attacks taken out of it depending
on where you live
you're also gonna have all the
percentages from your reps taken out of
it so suddenly
you've got like your 100 000 payday and
you're getting like
40 000 left of it that's yours and now
it doesn't look like such a fantastic
payday anymore
common misconceptions about what a
writer should do after their script is
finished
let's see one is getting your script
registered with the wga versus having it
copyrighted
versus mailing it to yourself i've
seen many writers who still believe that
if you mail your script to yourself that
counts as a copyright no it does not it
will not hold up in court
the only thing that will hold up in
court is a copyright where it has an
official document attached to it that
says this script was doc
was copyrighted on this date uh wga
registration
is still better than mailing it to
yourself but it's not quite as good as a
copyright
um especially with the way they change
uh like their copyright or their
registration and stuff only goes like
overall it doesn't go like per draft
whereas the copywriting you're going to
want to copyright
each thing that way you get proof of it
it's a little more expensive to
copyright but it's the safest
thing if one of those very rare
stealings ever happen what's a paranoid
screenwriter the people who are afraid
their stuff is going to get taken
people who won't send their stuff out to
competitions won't send their stuff
out to producers without an nda never
ever send an nda to a producer
be like oh you can't read my script
until you know they'll just
give you your nda back you're like well
then i don't need to read your script
um which i've met several people who
think that they need to send an nda out
in order to get a producer
no the producer is not going to send an
id you need to send an nda for the
producer possibly if you if you want to
work on the project that they're
needing to hire a writer for you know to
save their butts that you're not then
going to take their idea
and go write it yourself without them
but they
will not sign an nda for you
[Music]
how about put it in a drawer for a month
oh yeah um
i because you fall in love with your
writing
you you spend so much time coming up
with the story you think it's fantastic
it's gonna be very hard to find things
wrong with it if you still think it's
fantastic
so i put the script away
work on something else in the meantime
then come back to it because then i'm
not in love with anymore in fact i
probably have forgotten what some of the
stuff even was
and then when you're reading it you can
see all the stuff that now sucks and
you're like oh
this needs to be fixed like why didn't i
and you're going to feel dumb for not
knowing and i'm like why did i even
write this it doesn't make sense with
this part
but if you if you because you need to do
the rewriting like
like i said first draft sucks period end
of story across the board no matter
what you write it the very first thing
you write is awful
um and it's gonna need to be rewritten
in order for other people to see it
because again
you want like we said you want to send
your stuff out there
to to get eyes on it um but you want to
do that
once it's in the place where it's i
don't want to say this
where it's where it's good enough right
so you need to do the rewrites and if
you do rewrites immediately
you're probably not going to be changing
much because you all it's all still
fresh in your head about what you're
writing and why you're writing it
and the mood you were in when you were
writing it how much you loved it and oh
this song that was playing was so good
and so inspiring
and well now you're reading it a month
later you don't have that song playing
you don't really remember what why you
wrote certain lines of dialogue and now
you're like
wait this this character made a choice
it doesn't really make much sense and
why would this person talk like this
that doesn't that doesn't sound like her
why
so then you get to see all the flaws
coming out that you
wouldn't have known uh have they been
around like absence makes the heart grow
fonder with people
with scripts absence makes you realize
what isn't so great anymore
what's a serial starter and how do i
know if i'm one
serial starter is somebody who starts
writing a script
then gets an idea for another script
starts writing that script
i think it's an idea for another script
starts reading that script so they have
all these projects that they've started
writing but they haven't
finished any so i keep what i call an
idea book it's this little moleskine
notebook about like
palm size any movie idea tv idea
anything like that
i jot down the note in there i do not
bother writing anything
until i have finished what i'm currently
writing on because otherwise i'll
never finish um
so yeah serial starter is one who starts
project after project of the project
without ever actually finishing any of
them
with the mindset oh i'll come back to it
but you never will because you're always
going to have new ideas that are new and
exciting and fresh and you want to start
writing it
while it's fresh in your head and then
you just kind of
everything else kind of keeps getting
pushed further and further back as these
new ideas erupt
what is a uh a worrywart screenwriter
somebody who's constantly
fearful of the writing process
um someone who's constantly thinking
that they're not good enough
so they don't want to send anything out
um
somebody who is afraid of of
getting their material out there even
afraid of writing the material think
they have writer's block which doesn't
exist
by the way writer's block is typically a
combination
of either fear or perfectionism
or laziness those three things combined
make writers block
so we're someone who's afraid of getting
writer's block but it doesn't exist so
don't be afraid just
write your butt off um
yeah somebody who just they're not
progressing because they may be fearful
of success or fearful of failure
both of which are very real things which
i i
would have never thought why would
anyone be afraid of success
right well the problem is if you succeed
now there's all this pressure on you to
keep succeeding
so now you're it's almost like oh god
now i'm gonna fail or if you succeed
oh now i have to be a success i don't
know what a successful person looks like
how do i
maintain this i'm a fraud you know and
then you start
start getting into the whole uh like the
i'm not good enough
sort of scenario and all because you
succeeded and you
how do you how do you follow up that
success you know
fear of failure super obvious you're
afraid you're going to fall flat on your
face well if you never try
you can't fall on your face sure but you
also can't succeed
at that point what kind of work do you
do
before working on a screenplay what's
the pre-work
coming up with ideas which we talked
about a few different ways to try and do
that
um outlining is again like
for me outlining is the most important
process again it might not be for other
people
is for me i have to outline and hammer
that story out
before i even start page one of any
script whether it be tv or feature or
short or whatever um
so that's yeah that's my pre-processes
first coming when i when i first
and i come up with ideas different ways
some of them are from dreams i've had
some of them are from watching other
movies or reading other scripts
or doing the comp game of combining
things like that
um i actually was reading like i've been
reading some of the blacklist scripts
and i've actually come up with two ideas
in the last couple days that sprung out
of my head from other scripts that i was
reading
that have nothing to do with the scripts
i was reading but something that they
said in the script tweaked an idea i was
like oh that would be a really cool
what if i use like this line that they
use but then that strikes this whole new
concept you know
um so one of them like uh the the
mountain climbing
movie i was talking about haunted
mountain so they you know they're they
um she's along with climbing out and her
her team with her is basically making a
documentary about her
um you know so you've got like a bit of
a found footage like going back and
forth being like some found footage in
real life stuff
um so i was like okay well what if we
had took that found footage
aspect of it and we had somebody you
know also the point of the movie
of the the mountain climbing thing is
it's a mountain that no one's ever
climbed i'm like okay well we have
somebody
going going or doing something that no
one's ever done before and getting it
all on camera
and then i'm like oh what if we made it
a long distance space
travel movie and we take an elon musk
type character who's invented this brand
new uh
method of space travel and he's gonna be
the one to test it out he's getting
everything on footage and
boom had nothing to do with that script
other than
there's cameras involved and going
somewhere no one's ever gone before
so that came out of that idea and then i
read another script
about um it was it was a pilot i think
um no it was a movie it was a movie and
i'm coming up with a pilot
uh the idea i had was a pilot where the
uh
the guy they were they had this um
technology where they were
able to go into it was a uh i can't
remember the name of the movie they're
the script there's no blacklist script
it was a soldier who she had ptsd
and they were trying to like fix her
ptsd by
having instead of having regular therapy
sessions like this they came up with
this
vr scenario situation where they they
had taken
um all of the uh audio footage of like
the specific
um mission that she was on that kind of
triggered the ptsd
and she was having to relive it but she
was realizing there were things wrong
with the thing like they had some other
their facts wrong like
who went into the building first they
had wrong and they had like um
the color of a building right like some
minor stuff that seemed minor and but
later on the script became major things
so from that i came up with the idea of
oh well what if we have a tv series a
detective show
where they have this technology to
basically rebuild the crime scene in a
virtual world and go in there
and take different people's like the
different eyewitness testimonies and
then the different
like the splatter tests whatever and
they can rebuild the entire thing and
then see how the crime actually happened
i'm like that's in my head that seems
like a cool idea show that i would watch
you know i don't know
i'm not sure how many seasons i would
watch but but it's at least a cool
little idea
came from just like a piece of
technology you know so i come up with
come up with story ideas from pretty
much anywhere uh
either so i've seen stuff i've done
dreams
i write the ideas down in my idea book
where i have at this point literally
hundreds
of tv and movie ideas i think the last
time i actually counted it was 212.
um but that's it's just like a little
one sentence thing
some cases it's like just a title of
something that popped in my head
and whenever i need something new to
write i go through there try to
figure out what seems like viable ideas
right now what actually sounds
fun to write right now because not every
idea you have is going to be something
fun
um sometimes it's like big cool action
stuff and you want to write those and
sometimes it's like
very small personal dramatic indie type
stuff
you know that it might not be in the
mood for right now because it's going to
depress the hell out of you while you're
writing it
so find something that sounds good i
want to write then i spend time actually
coming up with okay here's the one
sentence where's the story in that
doing my outlining process for that i do
all my outlining by hand i find it much
easier for the ideas to flow when i'm
sitting there writing it out again my
handwriting is so bad that sometimes i
can't read it afterwards
i do my best um and then
i'll go through either rereading it in
there making changes in the notebook or
typing it all up and then realizing oh
this doesn't work and it can change
things
from the typed up version of the outline
and hammering it out till it's
bulletproof
and then i write the first draft of the
script that was a very long answer for
that question i apologize
what do writers get wrong with the first
10 pages of a screenplay
not being interesting i've seen too many
people have flashbacks in the first
couple pages
but it'll start with a flat what are you
flashbacking from if that's if that's
the first thing you're having happen
that doesn't make any sense um
not giving us enough about the character
we're going to be following
like a lot of a lot of horror especially
you know we'll start off with
something that's has to do with like the
killer like how they're killing people
but has nothing to do with the
characters we're actually
following you know so it's like a little
teaser thing
so it does its job in telling us okay
this is what the movie's gonna be about
we still don't even know who we're gonna
be following so i feel like in the first
10 pages you need to have
who we're gonna be following what the
story's gonna be about
be interesting for the love of god um
and give us some some reason to to turn
the page to go on to the next
uh pages and the rest of the script
did you like guardians of the galaxy the
first one i loved it the second one not
so much
why um i feel like they went too
big with the second movie um and then
couldn't wrap it up in a way that made
any sense
um they also i felt like in the first
movie did like a really good job of
um taking the humor and the action
and the drama and melding them together
in a good way in the second movie
i felt like they went way too much with
the funny because they
like that was what they were banking on
from the first movie was that it was a
superhero
movie that was kind of a comedy and now
they added too much comedy
and went too big with who the villain
was and they could never
get back to the main core of the story
and they kept the main characters apart
for too long
before they brought them back together
so it was like their character dynamics
they weren't able to play off of each
other because they were suddenly not the
same scenes anymore
and so all the stuff that worked really
well in the first scene the character
dynamics the comedy
um you know a medium level of
threat for them they just kind of like
went off and
off the handles and and lost track of
everything in that second movie
on the flip side what about sicario the
first one not even
not okay okay so we want as i was going
to ask what what
what do you think sometimes is the
breakdown between the first one is it
because
the the first film of of
a trilogy or whatever is is um
is a new world it's fresh the characters
are interesting because we want to get
to know them
but then we tire of them or and i'm not
saying that happened with sicario sure
again i don't see either of them so i
have no opinion on that movie whatsoever
oh that's a cool title um i would say
that
going from an original movie to the
sequel
the problem okay well
i feel like because you you need to
follow it up with something that's a
little bit bigger because the the whole
point of any
movie is rising stakes throughout the
course of it you know you're starting
with someone who's in their regular
normal world
and then with their lives and so
going from the first movie to a second
movie you want to keep that
going but i feel like the two big
pitfalls of a sequel
is either a it goes too far
um where it's like a huge leaps and
bounds beyond what the first movie was
and it's
how did they get there from here like
that's such a huge
jump or they don't have
even as big of stakes where they kind of
like pull it back a little bit too much
um i don't know that we get necessarily
tired with the characters
per se like i will watch every marvel
movie that ever comes out for the rest
of my life because it's
cool and i love it but i and i'm not
getting tired of the characters
because they are keeping it fresh with
the types of situations that the
characters are
in same thing goes with television
series you know they're constantly
getting
like more and more dramatic or bigger
and badder characters and they're
different types of characters
that they're having to face uh i
mentioned the flash earlier like
the problem with like the first three
seasons of the flash
the bad guy was always another speedster
so he's just going against somebody who
has the exact same power set
as him so then with later seasons they
started giving him characters who had
totally different power sets so i think
it was like two seasons ago maybe
possibly three they had uh the thinker
was his bad guy
you know where his hit the bat the
thinkers superpower was just
figuring out everything like five ten
steps ahead of the flash knowing
everything that's gonna happen
and can set up all the dominoes so they
fall exactly the way he wants it
um and then you know so it's like
something that
flash couldn't beat that because he's
really really fat he's a smart guy
because you know he he works uh for the
the police department you know in the
forensics department so he's a smart
dude
but his thing is think is moving really
fast so how does he compete with
somebody who is
thinking everything you could possibly
do no matter how fast you move he knows
all the possibilities
and has set up you know based on that so
it needs to keep changing and evolving
as opposed to just being the same story
over and over but you need to make sure
to not go too far with the evolution
to the point that it's not realistic
anymore
do you have a hard time getting people
in higher positions
to read your screenplays oh god yes it's
like it's the big catch-22 that is one
of those
like the conceptions that were true uh
absolutely is the catch-22
issue because people producers don't
want to read your work unless it's
coming to them from someone they trust
so if you don't have an agent you're
probably not going to get read by
netflix
in fact with netflix you won't even get
ready you don't have a show runner lined
up already even
um they because
there are so many people writing scripts
that first of all most of the scripts
coming in are gonna be from amateur
writers
and so they can't read all these
thousands i think there's something
like uh or was it 10 000 scripts get
registered with wga every year
that's not even counting like going to
copyright you know so that's a lot of
material coming in
and most of it is coming from amateurs
when you think there's only like 4 000
people in the wga
um so they're not going to want to sit
there and spend all their time doing
that so they're only going to read
vetted material and the ways to vet
someone is having it come in through an
agent
although that's different now with the
the strike stuff going on you know with
the wga versus the agencies
um or a manager that they trust or
another producer
that they know who who maybe has read it
you know and it's like oh this isn't for
us but it might be for you sort of thing
or if they have a personal connection
with you which is where the whole
networking thing comes in
um and if it's not coming from one of
those vetted
avenues or a screenplay contest if you
want a script contest then they'll
probably want to read it but unless
there's a way they can vet it
you're a nobody to them and they don't
want to read 10
000 nobody scripts if they have this
pile of like
10 that they trust and how did you get
your agent
i got i don't have an agent i have a
manager oh i'm sorry and she kind of
came to me
again it was through twitter that she
found me that's great uh
last year um during staffing season they
had the wga staffing boost
tag you know the wga staffing boost and
i had posted
something on on there that um
latoya morgan who had started it
like retweeted and that was where all i
think all these followers coming from
and then my manager happened to see
the two and was like well what kind of
stuff do you have and so i
pitched a couple things she looked me up
on indb and was like okay send me this
and this and she loved my stuff so
she's repping me and um sending my stuff
out there like i said
i got her at the very end of staffing
season last last year so it was about
time
i was even rep for her to start singing
stuff out like almost every show was
already
fully staffed so i couldn't really get
any meetings last year but fingers
across for this season i know i'm
they're they're still shooting pilots
um so a lot of things that are fully
staffed now are the stuff that went
straight to series already but the
things that just got pilot orders
uh they won't be doing staffing for
another like three to
two to five weeks basically you know
like beginning of march they'll start
probably um so fingers are still across
i know there's at least
three shows that i'm on a read list for
right now that
hoping that goes well but yeah so my
manager kind of just came to me
based on a tweet that's really cool yeah
especially after years of sending stuff
out to reps and
either them not connecting with the
material
or them meeting with me and we just
decided it wasn't a good fit
you know based on what they want to do
what i want i want to do and that sort
of thing so um
it definitely felt like a bizarre turn
of events to go from
me doing all this work of like querying
everybody and not really getting
anywhere with it
to be like here's a tweet about who i am
and what i write and then a manager
coming to me being like that sounds
great let me read you
you know so do you think you were just
ready though
would you have been ready two years
earlier i feel like i've been ready for
years
um maybe not for television as much
uh like i moved out here because i
wanted to work in tv my experience
before i moved out here was
like i had written a couple of specs for
existing shows to enter into the into
the
different fellowships and then i got
hired to write the eight episodes of
that british
sci-fi series that again still hasn't
even picked up
um but i feel like i'm more ready now to
deal with
people than i would have been when i
first moved out here having not known
what to expect because again when i was
in virginia all my communication was
either on the phone or via email
and now that i'm here i need meetings
it's all about the meetings
so i don't think i would have been able
to handle a meeting
when i first moved out here as was proof
like i said my first meeting two days
after i got here
was not good so now that i've met with a
bunch of people
and i've done the networking thing and
i've done talking and now i actually
know some people in the industry that i
didn't know when i moved out here
um maybe i'm in a slightly better
position for her to actually do
something
with with me you know i feel like though
people
in whatever pursuit they have out here
they need those like
couple bad experiences sure to kind of
like earn their stripes a little bit
you don't really know necessarily how it
all works
until you're in there you know you can
read all the book you can read this book
available on amazon um you can read all
the books you can read all the articles
that come through you can watch
all of the videos uh but until you're
actually
doing it yourself all you have is theory
you know it's kind of
doing it's like doing physics without
ever doing physics sort of thing you
know i i can read you
a textbook that doesn't mean you have
any idea what it all said until you sit
down and do an experiment you know
um so yeah those bad experiences are
what helps you move along to even
understand how the industry works
right and i think it it's good to get
knocked down a couple times because then
it just it's just there's something that
kind of fortifies you a little bit and
so when you actually have a good
experience
i don't know if you go as high because
you kind of
like it keeps you a little more
level-headed i think
i was trying to think of a great quote
it just fell out of my head
um but it's one of the things where you
you don't know what you have until
you've lost it sort of thing
okay so i feel like it's almost like a
reverse of that you don't know where you
can go until you've already like
seen the bad stuff like you don't know
how success is going to look so you've
seen how failure looks you know that's
true
i like that it's good you've mentioned
reading list a couple times
can you tell us what reading list sure
so like for the shows
um it's mainly a tv thing um
you know the show runner will get a
stack of scripts that they need to go
through so they can try and pick who
they want to hire for their
their show um so i've gotten a couple of
my scripts
on that stack but it just hasn't you
know like i said when
last year was at the very end of the
season so it was like they only had like
one spot left to fill by that point
and they still have a stack of scripts
there so but you can't even get on that
stack of scripts without the
representative
to like either manager an agent you know
pitching your stuff over there
you can do a little bit more with
twitter now because after the whole
thing last year
when the wga and the agents clashed
a lot of show runners like latoya morgan
and some others
uh liz alper um javier what's javi's
last name
i'm drawing a blank and hobby's last
name but like these big show runners
that are like okay well we're not
dealing with agents anymore so
writers who should we be looking at and
that's where the wga
staffing boost came in of writers who
are reading other people and be like oh
this person has this spec that's amazing
you need to check it out they would be
great in your room
before that it was agent or nothing
basically agent or manager or nothing
like
so you can't even get on this on the
list
i got myself on a couple of read lists
using the wga staffing thing
um those shows end up not getting picked
up so i didn't even need to really meet
with the the writers but it was like
writers who
had a show that was really cool to me i
loved the pilot when i read it
and they're like yeah if this had picked
up i'll i'll take a look at your stuff
you know that would have
would have never happened before the
whole mess with the wga and the agencies
last year
um so yeah that's what the list the
reading lists are is is the list of
scripts that the uh the shareholders
are supposed to go through and and it's
again if they don't have to go through
the whole stack they're not gonna
so if you're coming in there from a rep
that they trust or if another reader
they that they know
suggested you you're going to get read
before the ones that are just you know
randomly submitted to them
have you always had thick skin when it
comes to writing criticism
god no um i'm not even convinced i have
thick skin now
because i i'm i'm very good at taking a
note from someone and trying to figure
out
like how to fix it or if i don't
understand the note like how to find the
note within the note sort of thing and
see like if what the deeper problem is
to fix it overall
but i still there are still some notes
that
make me upset where i'm like how could
you not understand this it's
right there on the page um yeah
so it doesn't happen as frequently as it
did when i was younger and was newer
but and i try to keep that at bay where
if like
if something even irks me just a little
bit like thank you for the note and then
i'll come
back to it later and be like okay maybe
there was something there let's take a
look at it calm myself down
but nobody's perfect and i sure as hell
i'm not either
that's fine okay um
what would you tell someone who wanted
to quit their day job today
so that they could pursue screenwriting
full-time don't do that
don't do that again like there's i
couldn't find the chapters in the book
uh in a quick but you're not
you're not going to get rich right away
and you're definitely not going to get
rich
right away without having some way to
pay your rent
and there's no reason to go homeless
in the pursuit of it like there are
plenty of people
uh what's her name jk rowling like she
was
going again like how many like hundreds
of rejections before her book finally
got picked up
if she didn't have her job like she
would have been like homeless like
even more because i've read stories
where she couldn't feed her kids or
whatever
it's like that would have been even
worse if she had quit her job to write
that book
you don't quit your job until you even
and even once you've had a success you
know unless it's a tv thing where now
your new job is
writing in a writer's room um because
like i said
even if you sold your script for a
hundred thousand dollars
after you pay all your stuff you got
like forty thousand dollars and how much
are you making in the year right like
compare that to your job
like sure if you want to take a year off
but don't if you're
quitting it to start pitching stuff
that's insane i'm sorry
you like you need to pay rent you need
to
eat you need to feed your kids and
family if you have that
uh your dog would appreciate having some
food as well
like do not quit your job until
you are making enough of an impact where
you can just survive on the
screenwriting
that's great
what do you want 20 year olds to know
about screenwriting
20 year olds all right it's been a long
time for me i'm 36
now so uh
okay so not everything has to be a video
game or a comic book in movie form
those are great but not every movie has
to be like and they're not going to buy
your superhero script unless it's from
an ip
uh i've made the mistake of writing my
own superhero and nobody
cares because it's not it doesn't
already have the audience you know
that's where as horror you can come up
with original horror movies and it's
awesome we want to see it you can come
up with awesome action movies
it's original we want to see it don't
don't write adaptations
there's a don't write adaptations of
things you don't own the rights to and
second
don't write an original superhero movie
because nobody cares unless it's an
adaptation
it's a very oh interesting thing yeah so
if you can get the rights to a superhero
by all means
get the rights and then write it but
don't write your own superhero
and don't try to writing that adaptation
of something you don't own the rights
to i've seen a lot of people in the
forums like on
facebook who are wanting to write their
own
spider-man movie you don't own the
rights of spider-man no one will ever
see that in fact they may even try to
sue you if you try sending it to the
people who do own their rights to it so
um i made that mistake once again when i
was
first starting out i wrote a super a
superman script not knowing i couldn't
do anything with it
um i wrote an adaptation of the vagina
monologues
not knowing that i couldn't do that and
i got touched with people found out the
rates already owned so blah blah blah
didn't work
um that's that's the thing don't don't
adapt something you don't own because
you're just gonna
be disappointed and waste your time what
about
advice to 20 year olds on mindset like
don't get too high or too low
i think when you're younger and you come
here and everybody's so in awe
of young people in in hollywood um it's
easy to really
to go on these rollercoaster rides
because people are telling you how
amazing you are or
they're either telling you you're not
and then they just told you yesterday
you were
right so don't let
um rejection hurt you too bad
because they're not necessarily
rejecting you the person they're
rejecting your script
and a lot of people seem to take um
a rejection of the script as a rejection
of them personally like
like as if if because i didn't like your
script i hate you
i don't hate you i don't know you you
could be a wonderful person
but i don't like your script it's not
it's not a great story i'm sorry um
but it has nothing to do with the person
so don't let the rejections
be personal for you and on the flip side
don't rejoice at every minor
success or something that even looks
like a minor success because it can
still fall through
i can't tell you how many times i've had
this amazing looking deal that then just
gets
yanked out from under me for whatever
reason you know i would
i had a producer a few years ago who was
going to pay me like 20 grand
to write a pirate movie for him
and then all of a sudden his investor
who was giving him it was it was for
like a like an
80 million dollar budget or something
like that and
then he was like oh i have the money
blah blah i'm gonna send you the stuff
i'm gonna send you the twenty thousand
dollar check to start writing like next
week
didn't hear from him next week didn't
get a check so i call him up oh yeah so
my investor dropped out
um or another one where i was supposed
to get hired to write a sequel to
a horror movie and then like the
producer just
stopped communicating with me all of a
sudden no reason given just stopped
uh i even had one producer who literally
died
during our negotiation so that didn't
happen you know so it's like there's
always
always something that can make it go
wrong so don't start celebrating until
the check is cleared is
the the the the rule of thumb i've got
on that like i i'm
it's fabulous that people are interested
in my stuff but
until like there's a contract sign and
money in my hand
it could go wrong at any time and even
after then they're still playing movies
that
sell for millions of dollars the script
and then the movie never comes out
you know so uh stuff dies in development
hell every day you know uh
so nothing is a success until it's
100 successful what's your favorite
movie about the industry
i really like trumbo uh that was a
really fantastic movie
um why did you like it aside from brian
yeah
cranston's amazing in almost everything
he's even greeting that new mountain dew
commercial are you kidding me
um he's fantastic seeing
how the industry was at that time
is interesting to learn there's been
other movies that have shown that like
uh
you may have not seen the majestic with
jim carrey uh where he played a
screenwriter
who ended up getting blacklisted you
know um because they thought that he was
a communist or whatever
and there's the same time period and so
it's very interesting to see
how the the
all the world of hollywood is being
shaped by hearsay
yeah um and then to still see
how trumbo and his friends kind of like
circumnavigated the issue
in a creative clever way like yeah they
took a huge cut in their paychecks but
they still did what they
love you know and
yeah it was just a really interesting
look at
what the the industry was like back then
and then how people could get around
that
um and how they all changed today and
then again brian cranston's a
freaking genius
what's your biggest screenwriting regret
that i didn't move to la
sooner i had my first opportunity to
move to los angeles
in 2009 i think it was um
i was working on i was still living in
michigan at the time uh working on movie
sets as a production assistant
and myself another pa
and a makeup artist we're all discussing
moving out here together
um then one of them had
a uh a sudden like immediate death in
the family that
now they and and so now they had to be
the sole provider for their family
um and so they really okay now i can't
make the jump out to la
and without them the other person was
like
well i don't want to go if she's not
gonna go kind of thing you know and
so left just me and i could absolutely
afford to
still come out here on my own because i
had saved up all the money from like the
five or six movies i
and and two tv shows that i had paid on
out there
but i just didn't i i don't know
it was it was one of those fear things
where like it was a
fear of the unknown sort of thing you
know whereas like i was gonna be fine
coming out here with them as like a um
like a safety net sort of thing because
at least i would know somebody because i
didn't know anybody out here and so
i didn't have the courage the
film courage to come out to la when i
could have
the first time and so it ended up like
losing me
you know so many years because the time
i did move i was 2016
you know so now it's like i've lost like
eight years of
potential experience i could have had
out here well there was a lot of fear in
2009 because the recession
right so a lot of people didn't know
still what was going to happen
and a lot of speculation so
you know i wouldn't beat yourself up
over that it was a scary time yeah
sure and and it's one of those things
where you could
you know you could talk yourself up
about any bad decision you make
and and make it seem like oh well it's
understandable that you made that choice
at the end of the day i wussed out i
should have just
come out here um obviously certain
things would have gone differently i
would have never met my fiance
okay i love you um
you know and and stuff and or maybe i
would have but
you know by that point i would have been
hopefully bigger by now
um but it's one of those things where
like i
i feel like it was a missed opportunity
that i could have
started my life much sooner i guess um
rather than you know i would would have
been in my 20s
out here i could have gotten a job you
know as as like
either an assistant somewhere you know
whether it be a pa
on a set or being an assistant like in
an office or something like that
um but now nobody wants to hire a 36
year old
person you know as like the bottom level
thing because like the pay is like
minimum wage at this point you know it's
like when i'm 20
minimum wage is fantastic i can live on
minimum wage of course there's ramen
noodles
what can go wrong now that i'm in my 30s
minimum wage would kill me you know i
would never be able to afford my
apartment on minimum wage
i've couldn't you know hold up my my
current standard of living and stuff now
so it's like i feel like i lost out on
the chance
to live within the means that i had when
i was in my 20s
rather than the means that i've procured
over the years with the experience now
so i have more life experience
but it's less experience i could have
been sharing in hollywood and moving up
the ranks already so it's like i'm
already starting at square one
in my mid-30s rather than in my mid-20s
well this is total cliche but i don't
know if i always believe this but this
is the cliche saying everything happens
for a reason
i don't always subscribe to that and i
know it's just like can i get any
cheesier but
right um if we take that and dissect it
as much as it should be like on a mug
and you know somebody in front of
somebody's computer
do you think that's true or do you think
that we tell ourselves that
i think it's a combination because
obviously you can't
it depends on if you believe in fate i
guess um
i'm not a big subscriber in fate because
it takes away any choices i would have
had i guess
um so on on on that side like
it's not it doesn't work out
that everything's supposed to happen the
way it's supposed to happen because you
don't know how it's supposed to happen
that's true um and you can also
if things happen in a different order
you're gonna have a different place so
it's kind of a thing of
you would have a different life which
life would be better the life you would
have had or the life you do have
um so i don't really know it
i don't know where i would end up you
know like having been an extra eight
years in los angeles would i now be the
next shonda rhimes
or would i still be travis sepala trying
to be
shonda ryan you know like um would i
have a lovely gorgeous fiancee
or would i be alone or would i have a
different fiance
would i be hooking up with actresses
[Laughter]
like still wearing really well this is a
screenplay right here okay okay
you know it's um i think there's
actually a script that i just read
um it was a pilot for this current pilot
season i don't know if it got picked up
or not i think he got
bought picked up the pilot they haven't
announced if it's going i think it's
still shooting
i can't remember the name of it i'm
terrible at remembering titles but
it is a script that follows along this
character
and he makes he the show starts with him
at like a crossroads where he has
the option of either after his
graduation of either
going with his parents going with his
friends or going with this girl he likes
and then the story from there tri-sex i
guess you call it since he has three
different paths
what his life would be in each of the
scenarios oh and so yeah and so the show
kind of
goes along that where like it'll be like
seeing him
uh you know the the path where he went
with his parents because his
his dad and his granddad were both cops
now he becomes a cop
and so it follows along him being a
detective now in in this
in the city the path where he went and
followed
his friend is he went uh because he had
graduated with a
medical license he went and just you
know became a doctor and now he's a
doctor
and then the third path is he end up
like opening his own business and is
living with
the girl now and stuff and all three of
them have the
have the identical overall um scenario
that is happening and how it's happening
differently based on where he's at
so for instance in the pilot episode
which obviously i haven't read past
pilot because it hasn't gotten picked up
yet
is there's a congressman who gets
assassinated that in one aspect
as the cop he's you know following the
assassination and trying to solve it
when he's a doctor he actually saved the
senator so he didn't die from the
assassination attempt
and then with the friend or when he has
his business order he's in the wrong
place the wrong time and he gets killed
instead of the
or he gets shot rather and has to go to
the hospital and stuff
and as it shows like how his life would
be
drastically altered in these three
choices so i don't know where the show
is going to go from there but the pilot
i was like oh my god this is brilliant
like and and that kind of goes along
with what you're saying of like
you know would it be better like was i
determined was i
destined or determined to be where i am
now versus
had i made the choice to come out here
when i could have it follows along that
same thing as this tv pilot of like
there are different
forks in the road and each one leads to
a different place you know if you want
to go
with science fiction or
quantum physics and stuff you know of
like multiple parallel earths
you know there's the the multi-earth
theory where the an earth exists for
every possibility
so any choice you've ever made in your
life it automatically created new
parallel universes you're in the one
where you made your choice but then over
here you made the other choice
and there's infinite number of those and
so
i don't mean to go all quantum networks
and stuff but uh
you know it's one of those things i
don't know if i think i'm destined to be
anywhere because there's so many
outcomes that are possible i don't know
if i'm in the best place or if i would
have been in the best place or if
they're still best place or if
what's happening well i think we can all
look at our lives and say well
if i just done this earlier but we don't
know
if we'd done it earlier maybe we
wouldn't be prepared to handle certain
things
but you would also be in a different
place entirely and
would have like for instance i had one
choice that i could have made
the choice i made was to stay in my
hometown and
go to work and be a sous chef in my
hometown or
i could have gone to yellowstone
national park and ben
started off as a dishwasher there and
worked with the rings
how would things have changed if i would
have not stayed home with my parents and
gone to
yellowstone you know like who would i
have met who what would i have learned
what would have happened to me you know
i would be a very different human being
with that experience than i was staying
home working in a local restaurant
so i don't know if coming to la eight
years earlier when i could have
would have made a huge impact or
either for the better or for the worse
you know right
yeah i don't think for any of us we we
totally know yeah
do you think a great writer will live
forever through their work i'm gonna say
it depends on the story
we remember f scott fitzgerald for the
great gatsby but he wrote so many other
things that most people don't even know
exists
you know he wrote other novels he was
even a tv writer
nobody could i could never tell you what
episodes of anything he wrote
but i know he wrote television uh but
it's like everyone remembers him because
the great gatsby
like is all prey at the altar of gatsby
sort of thing you know
so but if if if he hadn't written the
great gatsby he's still a great writer
and wrote all other stuff but nobody's
ever read this other stuff
so and and i also feel that
it depends how timely it is versus like
current locale i guess um stuff i write
today
20 years from now are gonna seem blase
and
like out of place and out of touch and
and everything you know like we're
we're in in like a field now looking at
comedy for instance
stuff that is funny now
won't be funny later like you look at an
old simpsons episode
from like the early 90s it's not funny
anymore and
is kind of like racist in parts you know
the whole thing with
apu the character that they're
apparently axing a poo completely or
whatever
because people are complaining that it's
races but those complaints were probably
still there in the 90s we just didn't
hear them as much because
the internet has grown and people um
become more vocal
on their you know and are able to have a
place to
vent so like for instance when i was a
kid
um me and my sister are are big fans of
a christmas story
laughed my butt off at the end scene
when you know when they're in the
chinese restaurant but now
that's like the most racist scene you
can imagine basically
you know and it's like it was still
racist then but it was like
you didn't it was like we didn't know
better i guess as a society
and the way that we have a society have
evolved made it obsolete and
crass and should not be laughed at
anymore
so things from now may not live on
you know beyonce so like you could write
an amazing story but 10 years from now
your story may have
zero relevance sort of thing